Any other fighters still working on my music.
You know,
there's,
there's a lot of stress,
but it's all good stress.
There's so much going on.
There's so much on my plate right now.
There's so much shit that I'm doing.
You know what I mean?
If I want to put that all to the side,
we're off the air.
Yeah.
I used to and crashed Ustream.
You dirty bitches back on now.
Use Trim.
Silly.
They can't get their shit together.
Yeah,
it's,
it's uh,
I know one of the biggest problems people have been having lately,
the,
uh,
where you're trying to watch it back and it stops and then starts back up again
and it stops.
What's that from?
It's a,
they're adding new servers.
They're switching the super servers to new servers,
so that should be fixed pretty soon.
Complaining this is all free.
You is fun.
It's a nice,
most of the time we concentrated on the audio version of this thing,
but,
uh,
but I,
I don't mind.
I'm just to on,
I think it's gonna be,
seems fine.
Eddie Heights from the bottom line is,
I'm down anytime.
Talk to that.
I'm not the one turning it down.
Hey,
I saw you do your live show your music a couple of Sundays ago and I have seen
you,
I think,
uh,
the last three or four times you've done the viper room and this last time a
fucking amazing man.
You guys have really tightened your ship and it was really entertaining.
Like it was pretty legit this time that last time around.
Thank you very much.
The secret was you,
your grease,
the sound guy and the stage manager a hundred bucks each and they treat you like
royalty.
Exactly.
Really made it sound really good.
And usually those guys get paid $10 an hour.
They're like next,
another fucking shitty band.
Another shitty band.
They're just like not feeling it at all.
They don't want to hear anything.
Yeah.
It was a perfect $100 that wakes that fucking asses up.
Yeah,
that was good,
man.
You guys got to say it's like tipping a,
a stripper,
a hundred bucks.
That's deep.
You tip a stripper or 100 bucks,
you're going to take her to her maximum,
whatever that maximum is.
You tip a stripper or 100 bucks,
she's gonna go to the maximum.
Absolutely did.
She can get away with it.
The club.
Yeah.
Are you,
are you doing that like on a regular basis now?
You're going to be doing it like every month and a half,
two months or anything.
We're just playing and having fun and writing music and just produce and shit.
You know,
we got a lot of fucking new stuff.
It's taken forever to put this together because I'm a busy mother fucker.
Right.
I wish I could.
I moved closer to my recording studio.
I just moved to Sherman oaks.
The reason wants to get closer to that studio cause I need now start,
Shit's pumping.
You know,
I've got a couple songs on the number back down to soundtrack.
One of them's a theme song dropped as the theme song.
Oh really?
Yeah.
They were going to use originally the Jujitsu song.
I thought,
I mean,
when Michael Jai White,
the producer heard that he wanted that as a theme song right away.
Like,
like that second,
we're going to get Michael Jai white in here.
Yes.
So he's awesome.
He's a great guy.
He was a,
you know,
he as he was Tyson Tyson and spawned to spawn super fucking cool guy.
Like one of the most down normal guys who could ever hang out with.
It's just so like,
like no bullshit.
He's got like bullshit about them.
You know what I mean?
Like super like even normal cool dude.
Yeah.
Like the guys are good and he's a movie star man.
I mean he's,
he's fucking spawn,
you know,
but you're hanging out with them and he's like totally cool.
Totally normal.
You know,
it's got some great fucking story.
Has been a lifelong martial artist and fights Kyokushin tuck tournament still.
He still goes in there and those fucking bare knuckle punch to the CEC chest leg
kick,
head kick.
Tournament's macro shy white is no joke.
No joke dude.
I mean,
he no big,
he is six foot three,
six foot four 235 pounds of super athletes.
I mean,
and he's explosive.
I've been holy Shit.
I mean,
the stuff he does that he doesn't like a never back down to first of all,
never backed down.
One as if you don't know is the first MMA movie to go mainstream.
That was the biggest MMA MMA movie to date,
but it was terrible.
They made it into like the fast and the furious NMA and it was terrible.
But the one thing I remember,
the thing is these days,
right?
Everything seems to have the same sort of tone to it.
These young,
they're letting you know and like these fast and furious,
never back to any of those kinds of movies.
They're letting you know we're never going to get real deep.
Like we're all,
we're all just,
we're,
we're agreeing to this right off the bat what it is he like a music video.
What it is is these,
the people that can make movies and put them right in,
the guys that have that power,
they really don't know that much about MMA.
They just got into it and they're like,
I'm going to make an m and a movie.
I'm going to make them fighting movie mad like this.
Tap out stuff and they're the guys with the power.
They're not going to let the guys that could really put together an authentic
and then they movie,
how are they going to get their movie or this movie company can only,
it's only pushing three movies a year.
This one's only pushing 10 you know what I mean?
You're going to get yours on that spotlight.
Well,
someone did and obviously there are a bunch of knuckleheads that put that movie
together.
The first one,
the first one is really bad.
It's the stories always liked the new guy in town.
You know he's really handsome and all the,
all the other guys that are bad guys in town.
There's got to be hot chicks.
Sure.
Oh the meats,
the girlfriend and you know the,
the guy doesn't treat her good and this new guy does and it's the same formula
with it.
We could do a scary movie,
we can do it and then they move here.
Now we need to do a race car movie with that.
We're going to do a dancing movie where they like dance off.
Same story though.
It's the same guys.
It's the guys with the green light power.
They're not idiots.
They're not,
they just don't know the sport that well.
That's a,
they don't know how the little things that an NMA expert can just like pick it
apart.
Like the little things,
like they're fighting and they're fighting and like in the circle of people
standing out,
you know,
there's,
you know what I'm saying?
When Steven Seagal had become really famous,
they started a,
uh,
like a search,
like different studios were having searches of martial artists all across the
country find the next Steven Seagal.
And so they,
with me in New York,
and uh,
I don't remember what studio it was about,
but I said that the number one problem with martial arts movies is that a real
martial artist is going to look at that shit and go,
that's not real.
That can't happen.
That's,
that looks,
that's unrealistic.
And they were like,
crap,
they got arrogant with me.
They were like,
that's ridiculous.
No.
Who's going to know you?
And like a few other people,
believe me,
it doesn't matter.
Yeah.
It does.
It arrogant.
He was really arrogant about it.
I'm like,
I'm telling you as a person,
like if you're a guitar player,
okay,
and you're watching some fucking movie about the Buddy Holly Story and there's a
guy playing guitar and you know he's not really playing guitar.
That would drive you crazy if you saw some guy and he's doing this and the music
is coming out,
but you know this motherfucker is not playing that music.
Yeah.
It's that game plan as a musician.
Wouldn't that drive you fucking nuts?
Totally.
You can pick that out.
Yeah,
we totally crazy.
Yeah.
You always,
you always check the technique.
Yeah,
and I was telling these guys,
I'm like,
look,
there's some bad ass shit that you can do that's real,
that really does work and I can show you,
I can show you some bad ass shit that really works.
But all this flying double scissor kick two dudes at the same time.
That's silly nonsense.
This is silliness.
Like you're doing silly stuff.
I remember walking out,
I've never back down one going,
okay,
it sucked.
But at least they got the mainstream use to armbars and triangles and at least
it got them used to looking at fights.
Movie,
big movie fight.
Do you remember there's a triangle and arm bar that's kind of lethal weapon
whore.
Yeah,
that was the triangle.
Pouring Gracie was a fight coordinator for lethal weapon,
but in movies like that,
you see stuff like that every now and then sprinkled in,
but like in it never back down.
They explained it,
their training it,
it's like a new,
like a secret weapon.
So it,
they focused on it and I can and lethal weapon,
he gets him in a triangle,
but they didn't say,
wow,
look what he's actually doing it.
They just,
most people didn't even know that was a technique.
They're like,
oh he got,
he had him between his legs,
like they don't even see the technique.
You know,
I can't think triangle without thinking about rampage,
Jackson and Arona when enter ever anybody even mentions the word triangle.
All I think about is that fight because that was the craziest end to a triangle
attempt ever.
And rampage picked him up like a pillow and slammed them.
Do you remember we were over here watching that shit.
Do you remember how scary that was?
That was scary.
Look,
if you put that in a movie,
you would say bullshit.
You kept,
that could never really happen.
Yeah,
but you know how I think that's it hasn't happened since and we you,
you said this,
I'll never forget you said,
Ooh,
he might be dead.
Yeah,
we were watching this and you went,
Ooh,
he might be dead.
Like that was,
that was the key.
If you never seen that slam.
He's trying to get a Rhona's trying to get rampage and a triangle and rampage
defends it by picking him up over his head and slamming them down full force on
the ground and then head budding him if collided heads accidentally be just from
the impact.
It was a double.
It was a double whammy,
but if that would've happened on concrete,
he would have been a vegetable.
If he was lucky,
he was lucky.
He was probably going to be dead.
But if you're the best of like damn,
at least you kept him alive.
That's how hard it had hit.
His head exploded.
I wonder if that's affecting his career now and no FERC shore.
It is.
You think unquestionably that was a fucking violent knockout man.
That was an unbelievably violent knockout.
And then right afterwards circled you knocked him out number.
Yeah.
So that was two in a row.
You know when you get,
when you get bombed out like that there.
So could you,
one was brutal to man,
so could you out of the gate,
do you remember how scary that guy was out of the gate?
Out of the gate knocks out Nogueira Cheerio Noguera and then Arona two in a row
and does it like he's just going to steam roll everyone.
Yeah,
it looks like a mad destroy Jesus.
And then someone told me you got to watch a fight of his against Glover to
sharer.
You know who was one of the guys from a chucks?
Chucks camp from Slo.
Do Remember that guy?
Yeah.
Big really strong light heavyweight.
But he had like,
these are problems.
I think we had a really scary dude,
dangerous,
dangerous dude.
And He,
uh,
he,
he fought,
soca,
June broke him,
he fought so joint,
stopped him with strikes and then you know that this was all after that.
That was apparently early,
early on he says it wasn't like one of those guys that almost maybe got thrown
into the deep end too quick.
Yeah.
It's never too late for,
so could you suck that you'd just focused on,
on getting really good at Jujitsu and not,
and not end up like a one of those fighters,
you know,
one of those Olympic wrestlers that never learned Jujitsu,
you,
if he falls in love with Jujitsu,
continues to progress with the striking,
he's going to be a force.
But he's,
if he doesn't learn Jiu Jitsu,
if he doesn't fall in love with Jiu Jitsu,
his chances are very slim of,
of getting to the top.
It's real weird when you see,
you know,
you always like to say,
well,
you know,
there's certain amount of loss as a fighter has and then they're done.
But every now and then there's a guy who comes along that just defies that shit
that like loses a bunch of times with then gets it together and then start
sweating.
Jorge Santiago,
he's a good example that Anderson Silva was just run of the mill Leo Machida for
a few years.
They were like,
ah,
he's all right.
So the fighters right now that you're thinking of it,
I mean,
I'm talking about losses,
I'm talking about bouncing back from loss.
Machida,
you know,
only bounced back from the shogun loss.
But like Allister,
Allister over him,
I think he's been stopped nine times.
Bobby Hoffman stopped him,
you know,
uh,
he,
he got submitted by Verdugo.
Harriton off,
stopped him.
Chuck stopped him.
A lot of guys stopped him.
And if you looked at him on paper with all those stoppages,
you'd say,
well how is this guy ever going to be the best?
But then you look at him now,
Shit,
he's one of the best man.
And his Jujitsu is good.
Yeah,
kill you with.
Yeah.
And he's,
he is striking is no one's close deck.
That mother fucker is the Strikeforce Grand Prix champion and,
or the,
excuse me,
the k one Grand Prix champion and the Strikeforce champion and the dream
champion.
Who the fuck has ever been able to do that?
Do kickboxing at the highest level and MMA,
the thing that saves over is that he mastered the Guillotine.
Anybody tried to take him down?
You got to take them down.
I mean most people aren't going to try to stand with them.
There's gonna to be a couple,
you know,
brave motherfuckers out there that try to stand with them.
There will be an MMA
but usually they're going to try to take him down.
They got to worry about that getting his,
getting his death.
He's,
he's fucking submitted Vituro with it and he's,
he's good in his ground.
Game is good too because his brother Valentine over him.
He hasn't had a successful career as of yet.
He still fighting,
but he's a real smart guy and is in love with Jujitsu.
Valentine Overeem's Jujitsu.
Really,
really good.
That's his brother.
So it's,
it's rubbing off on him cause cause uh,
um,
Overeem Alster one lone star,
he run the uh,
Abu Dhabi European trials or something like that.
Don't quote me on it,
but I know his Jujitsu is good and that's the key.
All you guys out there,
I know I had never fought,
but in my opinion,
I've been in the business getting paid since 2000.
That's watching fighters come and go watching fight camps come and go meeting
all these guys and get it.
I'm like,
I'm experiment.
Like I go through their lives and it's never too late to get your career
together.
You have to fall in love with Jujitsu.
Of course you need like the mental state together.
You got to have,
you kept,
you don't have a fragile ego and you gotta,
you gotta have a warrior's mind.
But if you have a warrior's mind,
you love to fight,
you'd love to train.
You have a great worth work ethic.
Please fall in love with some Jujitsu,
fall in love with it.
Then you become dangerous on the ground.
A wrestler who is not interested in learning how to take people out.
That's like a basketball player,
not interested in like shooting the ball.
I just want to dribble.
I'm just going to dribble.
I don't need to shoot the ball.
Look at me.
I'm a great dribbler.
Yeah,
you're dribbling is awesome.
You got to get good at closing the show,
making some points.
How could you be a wrestler and not be in love with choking next fall in love
with it.
Study Marcello Garcia.
He's got a website,
30 bucks a month.
If you're in an MMA right now and you're not studying Marcello Garcia,
you're behind the times.
He's the number one guy in Jujitsu,
number one,
and no Gi Jujitsu.
No one's better than him.
If you're an MMA fighter,
fall in love with Marcello Garcia.
That's a great start.
Jeff Glover,
another great start.
If you fall in love with Jeff Glover and Marcella Garcia bone,
both of them.
You know what I'm saying?
Any glass of course or some dude who just likes to stand.
Yeah,
that's good too,
but you're going to go so far.
They in,
in what I've seen working backstage and all these goddamn shows for the UFC for
eight years.
That's what I see.
I see the guys come and go,
come and go.
And the main thing at the very top,
at the very top,
even if you're a Brazilian jujitsu black belt and you won the Mundey hours a
bunch of times,
what I see,
I see the prelims for the last eight years.
A lot of people don't see what's going on in the prelims,
just getting signed.
If you're under one 70 and you get signed to the UFC,
that doesn't mean shit.
You got to get through the prelims to get to the main card.
You know how many fights you got to win to be on the main carding here?
170 pounds.
They're going to put you on the main card.
You gotta,
you gotta win more than than two fights and you better be exciting.
So getting signed to the UFC is like those,
and I've used this before,
it's like those turtles that they're born,
they're hatched in the,
yeah,
you're born,
yeah you're alive.
But now you got to get past the seagull and all the crabs attack and you good
luck making it to the ocean.
The main card.
Good luck.
It's really hard in the guy.
My point is there's a,
I see a lot of guys come and never make it to the prelim.
It's been a lot of Brazilian Jujitsu,
black belts out there.
I don't want to say any names.
A lot of them come through and they just get smashed by wrestlers.
No one ever sees it.
No one ever talks about it.
It's not on the underground and they just disappear.
There's been a lot of them.
There's God,
there's been guys that rise in our stars like Charles Olivera and that Rocher
guy.
I liked those guys.
I want them to,
you know,
they,
their submissions look slick.
Nogi but there's a lot of guys they get,
they can't get to the main card cause they couldn't get past the elite wrestler.
Even though there were a black belt and the in the g they're on their back.
The guard is okay.
Sometimes things catch,
but overall I see a lot of guys lose decisions because they're on their back
against them.
Average college wrestler,
they couldn't get past,
but I see that a lot.
That's what I've seen.
Unless I,
unless I dreamed it or it's a like an like I'm having delusions.
That's well,
that's what I thought I,
I see.
I see a lot of guys come through.
They don't have the answer for the elite wrestler.
You,
if you haven't wrestled your whole life,
guess what?
Most of the guys at the top have wrestled and you better have the answer for
them.
That's your worst nightmare.
You better be training for that wrestler right now because that's what you're
going to hit.
And every year,
more and more wrestlers are quitting their job at fucking home depot and they're
watching the ultimate fighter go.
And I could be famous too.
I wrestled 23 years.
Fuck this life.
They got three kids,
they hate their wife.
There's a lot of these guys coming.
They're coming.
They want to be famous too.
There's a new celebrity in town and it's the MMA fighter and these guys,
they're a bunch of them that judo guys are going to shoot.
I could do it too.
I almost went to the Olympics and judo.
There's all these guys coming up.
What are you going to do to them?
These guys are used to being on top.
They'd been wrestling since two.
You're going to start wrestling now.
If you haven't wrestled your whole life,
your guard better be amazing.
A better be Ninja when they talk about your guard,
you think you're going to make it to the top and MMA and you haven't wrestled
your whole life.
If they're not talking about your guard like it's fucking phenomenal.
So dangerous.
Stay away from the scar.
It's amazing.
If they're not saying that about your guard,
your chances are slim that you're going to get past the elite wrestler cause
you're not going to be on top for sure.
And it's a 50 50 beat 'em strike.
If you beat him striking,
you know you might win a few.
These new young guys,
man,
all of them are super equipped.
Like this Michael McDonald kid,
that font this weekend.
Did you see that fight?
I didn't see that.
Oh my God.
What
a fight.
Edwin Figaroa,
Michael McDonald,
they fought at 145 prelim one 45 or one 35 I think it was one 45.
Forgive me if I'm not sure.
Yeah,
it was one of the prelims that aired on like Facebook or one of those things
maybe with spike and I think it was Facebook though,
is fucking kid is super talented dude.
Super talented.
And both of them are the Figaroa took the fight on six days notice and cut 20
pounds to,
to make the weight class.
I'm pretty sure it's one
35 either way.
Um,
uh,
Figaroa cut all this fucking weight and uh,
was getting his ass kicked in the first round but then just gutted it out and
starts going after him.
And the second round and the third round,
dude,
it was a just a crazy fucking fight.
But this kid,
a Mcdonald had him in a triangle armbar combination.
He had his back.
He just,
it was,
it was sick,
sick display of striking and Jujitsu together and these fucking 20 years old
man,
all these new guys that are coming up,
they can do everything.
They can wrestle,
they can do Jujitsu,
they're good off their back.
They're all good off their back.
They you have to be,
that's the next stage.
There's no getting past that.
There's no way ultimately being having an average guard like most,
you know,
just most typical MMA fighters,
just that average guard that we're seeing now.
That's if you have that you're gone.
Well,
I felt it the days of a guide not being good at any of the aspects of MMA or on
the way out.
There's not that many room.
There's not that much room left.
It's like it's like every other sport man.
It gets broken down to its bare essentials and everything gets exposed and now
that we know the bare essentials there,
it's real simple.
You have to have all of them in place.
You have to have wrestling,
you have to have striking,
you have to be good off your back.
You get on top,
it's a science and we've,
both of us have worked backstage and we see these guys come and go.
It really is a strange perspective for me.
I'm getting to see what every fight I see in the truck for the last eight years.
I'm analyzing what works and what doesn't.
I'm constantly doing the research and talking to these guys seem come see him.
[inaudible] I could put careers together like charts,
you know,
Emily as a weird arrogance to not want it to learn some aspects of the sport.
Yes,
that's,
that's the problem.
Basically.
If,
if the people you roll with it,
this is,
you know,
if you're an MMA fighter and the people you roll with aren't talking about your
Jujitsu,
like it's amazing,
man,
your chances are slim.
That's why people eventually you see these stars rise.
And again,
this is all coming from a guy,
a scientist studying charts backstage.
I've never fought.
I'm not a bad ass.
I'm not an athlete.
I'm not this tough dude.
I just,
I just noticed things.
That's all I notice.
Things,
you know,
uh,
on a,
on a hyper level.
And I notice that the fighters that come and go,
the ones that come,
if you put them on,
I can't name names,
that's the problem.
Go See,
seem common.
You then you see them go.
If you put them all together,
they,
they're Jujitsu was never discussed.
One common denominator was their digits.
It was probably never discussed as something lethal at their own gym.
You know what I mean?
Probably not.
I could,
I could go on all level.
There's a lot of guys who can get away with just wrestling and really good
striking for awhile.
Fight for awhile.
Yeah.
If you can keep the fuck gotta be good at everything and people are leaving out
razor sharp,
finishing Jujitsu,
then leaving that out.
There's a lot of guys that are spending most of their,
their their time working on the striking,
which is great.
But I think the main concern as you know what,
I'm going to be as tough as I can.
I don't want to be exposed.
I don't want to get,
not,
I'm going to do everything I can to not get knocked the fuck out in front of the
world.
So most people on the striking,
I totally understand that.
But you have,
if you want to make,
if you want to fight,
if you want a long career and you want a long successful career,
you have to fall in love with Jujitsu.
And that means you have to get into,
you have to study.
The top guys in the top guys are Marcello Hydro,
Gracie and Jeff Glover that just the most beautiful Jujitsu.
Just watch that and you got to start getting into that.
If you're not into it and your career's not going that great,
ask yourself that question.
Think about,
think about what I'm saying.
Um,
you know,
you got to fall in love with Jujitsu.
You have to not just striking,
especially if you want,
look,
if you like fighting,
you're going to want to have a career that's long and yet you're going to want
to take as little damage as possible.
And if you don't have like a really good submissions of that option isn't in
your toolbox at all times,
you know you're going to,
you're going to engage in longer fights in necessary.
You're going to get more damage than necessary.
You know,
there's guys that uh,
would see,
you know,
that I have equal striking,
but one guy will see an opening for a submission and jump on it once he's,
even though he's striking with the guy because he recognizes is the correct
thing to do,
that it's there and,
but for some guys they don't have that option in a toolbox.
And if you don't have that option in your toolbox,
you're going to have a longer,
you're going to have longer fights,
they're gonna how they're going to be more brutal.
You're going to take more damage
and you have less options and you can get her overall,
whoever has the less options is going to do not as good.
And if there's more time fighting,
there's more time you're getting hit,
there's more chances of you getting hurt.
It's that simple.
It's really that simple.
If you want to lengthen your career,
you want to be as effective as possible.
And if you want to have the most dynamic career,
you want to be as effective as plot,
take whatever the fuck is there.
That's why George Saint Pierre,
so good.
Joseph George Saint Pierre never commits to doing anything.
I mean he might be,
he might be.
He might decide the game plan is to box you,
but if you take him down,
it's not like he hasn't been working on his guard.
It's not like he hasn't been working on getting right back up to his feet and
it's not like he's not really comfortable strangle you on the ground.
If it's there,
he's not going to stand up and let you stand up and start banging it out with
you again.
If he sees an opening,
he's going to take it.
He's going to strangle you.
Oh,
are we ever going to see George singing Pierre be put on his back?
He fight some guy that just putting him on his back at will and we're going to
have to see how good George Saint Pierre as guard is,
this thing that'll ever happen.
Fight easily.
Could be that Jake shields could easily get ahold of George.
Yes.
I think standup wise,
standup wise,
George is very fluid.
He's much more fluid.
He's he's,
he's more capable.
His Jab is nasty.
That that uh,
he does that Superman Jab to at fucks you up with it.
He's,
he's nasty on his feet,
man.
His leg kicks George.
Oh for sure he's nasty.
He,
he wants a kickboxing contest with Tiago albums basically.
I mean that,
I mean there was some take downs in that fight,
but the kickboxing part of it,
the standup part,
George won that shit.
Georgia's a beast.
So Jake is at a significant disadvantage standing up.
But Jake is a mother fucker.
Dude have,
it's
a hold of him.
If he gets that fucking double under hooks on George and really squeezes,
if somehow or another you finds himself in a position where you know,
George zigs when he should have zags or he somehow or another gets him pressed
up against the cage and actually gets a hold of them,
things get real interesting man.
Things get real interest.
It's all,
it's all about how they're going to match up.
I mean,
I could see,
I could see it two ways.
I can see Jake shields taking maybe 90 seconds to pass Georgia's guard and then
he finally passes and then within a minute he sinks in a rear naked choke or
some good teen and then puts him out and you're like,
wow man,
he and he took his time,
but he sort of went through Georgia.
I could see that maybe or I could also see him not being able to pass George
Sand Pierre Guard,
George Saint Pierre has garden might be insane.
Like by this time,
the last time we saw it,
I think it was maybe Carl prison or something.
I forget the last time we saw it,
but he was on his back.
I don't think he did that much,
but now who knows?
Yeah,
he's preparing for navy.
Yeah.
Maybe his maybe Jake shields,
cat past Georgia boy.
He passes the half guard and then he passed the site control and then he
recovers and like,
damn,
he's got a pass again.
One of those battles,
one of those chess matches and if it's like that,
maybe later on the rounds,
George Saint Pierre has a child tired.
Jake shields.
Jake shields is able to get like one take down out of three or four attempts.
He's able to get them,
drag them down,
but damn,
now he can pass his garden.
He's getting tired now he's got to stand and he's taught.
That could happen too.
Or he could go through them.
Fuck,
who knows?
It's a total mystery,
a total mystery.
It can go both ways and I'd go,
Oh damn.
And went that way.
I'm super excited for that.
Who knows?
In another scenario is Jake shield cannot take down George Saint Pierre.
Not even once.
That's another scenario.
Sure.
That,
I mean,
if that happened I'd be like,
damn,
it's rustling wasn't good enough because if you look at Josh Koscheck,
man,
Josh Koscheck on paper was a better wrestler than Jake shields on paper.
He did more in college.
He was like,
uh,
an all American,
maybe a national champion once I think.
I think he was the best chocolate delta and Josh Koscheck was the best college.
How fast.
Yeah.
So he couldn't fuck with GSP would have Jake shields can't take down by as much
as possible to fuck your ass boss.
Well maybe he takes him down super easy or maybe it looks like,
like if you were,
you know,
an interesting thing with the Phil Davis Nogueira fight was Phil Davis could not
take down to log in that first round and it looked,
it looked like for me if I was still,
David says coach,
I'm like,
man,
you can't take them down,
but you know what Phil Davis kept doing.
He kept trying and then the second round he just kept trying and then he finally
got him down.
He switched it from doubles or singles,
so he just kept fucking plugging away with the wrestling.
A lot of wrestlers at that point,
what he just said,
fuck it.
I'm going to stand with them and take my chances there will Phil Davis is so
confident with his wrestling.
Yeah,
he just stuck with you.
Here is post fight interview.
He had a lot of physical problems coming into this camp and apparently,
yeah,
you got an injured a couple times and he was having some real problems where he
wasn't sure if it was going to go through the fight.
You see how fast he flicks up those?
The head kicks,
dude,
Holy Shit.
He landed that front kick to the face like a person does too.
It's crazy.
His,
his legs are so powerful and so fast.
He just springs up.
God,
he's down.
He's got the most ridiculous mesomorphic build ever.
As far as like you look at like the classic Mesomorph,
you know where's there's,
there's different body structures.
ECTOMORPH was it?
What does it was the other one,
I don't know any of those morphs spreads or more I have to morph endomorph
endomorph endomorph is always like,
I never spend a penny over waves.
Ectomorph is like really skinny and Mesomorphs are like really wide shoulders.
It heavily muscled,
like really like super athlete builds and he's got a perfect mesomorphic built
his like his hips are like really narrow,
but then it flares out to like big shoulders.
You know,
he's a spectacular,
like,
like the way he looks like he's like a bulldog.
Yeah.
Well no,
it's like,
it looks like like a fucking,
like a comic book Superhero.
Isn't it weird that it's kind of,
it's like,
like on the,
on the fence of being racist.
Kind of like if you bring up,
you know,
there's an incredible Ari gold,
ah,
oh,
they've African,
you bring up the African American athlete is like,
just takes over all sports is like,
you know what,
I can talk about that.
A guys who look like guys like Phil Davis and John Jones,
they work fucking incredibly hard.
This is not just a matter of guys who are just genetically gifted and they don't
have to try.
No,
no.
They're there until the Dana Bowl.
Both those guys have in common besides being black and besides being super
athletes as they're both super fucking driven.
They work really hard and they're both really intelligent guys who know what
they have to do and go throughout and didn't do it.
So that when anybody questions what they've done to get where they are,
they're like,
well fuck you.
You know you don't,
you don't have no idea how much work I put in.
This is not easy,
but they're still better at it than other people.
I mean,
yeah,
it's just,
it's like they got,
they got the,
all the ingredients you can't have,
you can't be a natural gifted athlete and not work hard.
That's not good enough.
You've got to have both.
You got to work hard and that the edge is the natural stuff is the edge.
I'm no super athlete,
but when I was doing taekwondo,
I know there was certain people that I had physical advantages over there were
undeniable.
Just having larger bones for my size,
being able to hit harder.
You know,
there's certain certain things that you,
you there underneath.
Isn't that weird how it's kind of racist to talk about that?
She could talk about it myself though because I'm Italian.
But you know Joey Diaz was talking to me about this on the,
on the phone the other day.
He's like,
Yo family though.
Fucking masons,
masons from Italy.
Those guineas,
those guineas make good masons cause everybody else tapped out.
Everybody else just like,
fuck this.
I'm not carrying rocks.
The guineas like,
fuck you,
I'll carry these fucking rocks.
And that's what it,
I mean it's,
it's no,
no different in a racist way.
Then the idea that,
you know,
African Americans were at one point in time slaves and they were bred to be
larger and stronger.
You know,
why is that?
Why is that racist?
Is that people got fired?
Uh,
Jimmy,
absolutely.
Isn't that like been a proven fact?
Is it,
is it a proven fact?
I don't know.
It's like it's actually kind of racist.
You can't bring,
yeah,
it's totally racist to say that they have the fucking greatest bodies of all
time.
Why is that?
I wish just to say they're the greatest athletes ever.
Michael Jordan.
I mean,
could you stop?
Fuck is a greater athlete than Michael Jordan.
You remember when we were kids,
he used to see those pictures of him flying through the fucking air.
What was the last time a white guy was flying through the air and a basketball
game like that?
I mean,
he could fly,
he'll eat.
You remember those photos in sports illustrated?
We you like,
there's no way that's real.
There's no way that guy's that high in the air.
He could fly.
It's,
it's,
it's like a,
it's the reason it's like,
it's they think,
I think the people that think it's racist see it as when they say,
if you bring it up,
it's almost like,
yeah,
you're a better athlete.
But you know,
it was because we are,
when you run out of Maine,
it's a direct,
you know what I mean?
It's that kind of feel like it's,
well,
I could see that.
Yeah.
All my relatives are from,
from Italy and Ireland,
so nobody owned anybody in my family.
So I don't have any,
might pay half black Gerald.
Well,
I'm mostly Sicilian.
So if you follow the movie true romance,
there's a lot of black in my past,
that sense of beauty.
You know what,
if I could,
uh,
had a time machine and I can go back and I could like mess with parallel
dimensions and Universes,
I would choose a life where I was in a world where all the Mexicans were
enslaved.
I,
they got created PR like amazing athletes.
And then I was a by product of that.
I would like for me right now,
I think that would be a,
that's a cool background,
right?
Like people were enslaved,
you know,
for me,
I don't understand that.
Like,
you know,
cause I'm not black so they have a whole different feelings.
I think if I go back into my history,
if I can get a time machine and go back to the history of my Dna,
I think a long evolution,
you know,
if evolution is real and if one point in time we were actually lower hominids
and we evolved to become humans and these hairless apes,
I think there must be stages along the way.
You know?
And I think at one point in time,
one of my great,
great and sensors fucked a monkey probably shouldn't have been fucking anymore.
You know what I mean?
It was like one crazy McGee.
There's probably going to die out.
One crazy wild monkey and this more evolved monkey was like God damn,
but I am horny and he shot a load of the crazy monkey and that monkey became
like this hybrid and that's where I,
that's my genetic lineage.
I definitely came from,
I definitely have a just a hair more monkey in them than the regular person.
There's no doubt about it.
I mean if,
if we,
if you look at evolution,
you know,
you look at like evolve people,
you know who looks evolved to me.
Asian people do Asian people,
they have less hair.
They're fucking awesome at math.
They're incredibly hard workers.
You know,
they're talking about having these,
these,
they're going to have this,
this thing in Japan where the nuclear power plants have melted down.
Dude,
a bunch of people more than 50 are going to die for sure cause they went in
there to clean that shit up.
Like they sacrificed themselves.
That shit would never happen if with my people,
anybody in my family,
anybody with my genetics,
that's not happening.
My culture,
this is not happening.
We're not going to do that.
Who's the Japanese to me that seems to be the most of all.
So that's against me
and,
and I think I'm closer to a monkey then
these people are,
I'm a racist against myself.
Speaking of fucking animals,
have you seen that vice guide to like where they,
they fucked donkey's?
Yes.
In Colombia.
Holy Shit.
That I didn't think they would actually show it or show like a 12 year old shows
trolling if they're trolling us.
It was all,
I don't get in trouble.
They'd be in trouble at ready when that does.
The 12 year old goes like,
I like to spread the pink pussy a part in it.
I love the fuck.
Did Donkey policy like on keys?
Yeah.
It's so disturbing.
Who are the jerseys?
Get Colombians.
The catch these guys fucking donkeys.
And it's like,
there's a whole bunch of them talking,
talking.
So I came in cold in this part of Columbia.
If there's people fucking animals anywhere it's happening in all cultures.
Would this part of Columbia,
it's,
it's kind of well known in their,
in their society that uh,
your first,
uh,
sax is with a donkey.
Like it's normal.
Like how weird is it
that that is going on the exact same time your neighborhood is going on or your
neighborhood is going on.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you know,
you think this is all happening at the same time on this planet.
There's parts of this planet that are in a totally different frequency than we
are right here.
Yeah.
If I lived in Columbia in some third world country or like that,
I'd probably be fucking a donkey every now
fuck it.
What else is there to do?
It's probably not enough checks.
All the good ones get taken up by the dictators.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
They all get the best ones.
They get swooped up to imagine how much it must suck to be born into some really
fucking crazy little small country that's super poured as dirt roads and you
don't even realize how fucked up everything is until one day you'd go somewhere,
there's a TV and he look at the TV and you see like Manhattan and Shit and
buildings and skyscrapers and people eaten dinner and juicy steaks.
You're like,
what the fuck?
Like where's all this happening?
And you're,
you're stuck with no shoes on your,
you get your shoes are made out of water bottles.
You ever seen those kids?
They make flip flops at a water bottle.
That shit.
Yeah,
that's going on right now,
man.
Going on right now in the world.
They also said that in that documented that there was like,
sometimes there's like that one slutty donkey that's just walking around the
streets and he's like,
and then sometimes I was so horny I would not even use a condom and now fuck the
neighborhood donkey sluts.
Jesus Christ,
you know,
she fucking cheaper Reeves is a huge,
you know she fucking,
yeah,
I remember that.
She Vagina pit mockumentary never even close to that get made.
What was it?
Well we were talking about sheep vagina,
like maybe she puts,
he's like way better than regular pussy.
Like it's supposed to be now it's supposed to,
she puts these supposed to be like wait,
like as realistic to a real pussy as possible.
But it gets so good and the bid is,
it gets so boring muscular.
It's a 20,
20 mockumentary like,
like this is already what's happening.
Put,
she puts,
you are so good that it leaked into the city.
People started sneaking it,
you know,
living with sheep and the city and it got,
it got to be a big problem and everyone's fucking sheep and um,
that's it.
Have,
you know,
there was like violent murders and stuff.
There was,
remembers,
Oh,
there was a sheet problem that wasn't sheep's.
Sheep's would start murdering other sheeps.
Yeah,
because they could,
if they smell get jealous,
they feel great.
They felt were way better than a female vagina.
So everyone's into it.
Everyone loves their sheep.
Everyone's got sheep at their houses.
Everyone's got,
but if you cheat on your sheep,
if they smell sheep on you,
they'll attack you in,
in like each a dick and just kill you.
Like on like a chimpanzee dude's got murdered and it's becoming a problem and
there's a line sheet vagina.
And they had,
we had sheep,
sheep,
gang war with a sheep would go into the next door,
neighbors and fucking house and killed her.
She,
but if he had to fuck one animal,
what's,
what's kind of animal would you,
you would do it.
Just go with the flow,
man.
He figured it out.
You know what I mean?
All that shit.
Giraffe.
No,
no,
not worth it.
But suddenly on sheep for some reasons,
a reason,
let them do the groundwork.
I believe in this and if they tell you that those peppers or hot,
trust me,
it's cause somebody ate them.
You wouldn't go to Joey just discovering that he just started fucking sheet
pussy and he's like telling you how great it is.
Listen,
cock sock of that.
Forget.
Forget that fucking fleshlight.
Whatever that nonsense is.
Listen to me sheep.
There's a reason why those fucking pharmas and month Montana and up then Beaut,
those dudes would let them faces.
Looks like fucking catches them.
It's smoking Marlboro's and fucking sheep dog all day long.
That's what they're doing and those guys,
they know about New York.
They go,
fuck you.
I don't want to leave.
I'm good.
I got my refund.
I got my sheet.
I'm going to shoot a fucking bear this afternoon.
Listen got stuck up.
She puts the,
it's where it's at.
They got it right to live in by streams while we hear like fucking animals in
Burbank took me an hour in traffic traffic dog to get the fucking la.
It ain't right.
That guy's got a nail.
These fucking sheep smoking joints from his mouth,
the gods he is.
I think I would go crazy and fuck a dolphin if I had to choose or just go really
crazy and fucked like Mcdonald's or like a bullfrog dolphins.
The dolphins going to fuck you son.
Okay.
No,
I'm saying so ladies and a hundred pounds.
Any animal muscle.
I'm saying any animal like like you could have a tiger if you wanted to.
They would like sedated enough,
get it,
you know some roof roofie and date rape but tiger,
that's dolphin.
The date rape,
any animals is what I'm saying.
Because a dolphin what you would actually have like a spiritual connection.
There are still some hard enemy.
Slimy or shipped often in the eye and like,
yeah,
like you could actually fall in love with it doesn't always fucking tricks for
you.
It sucks your Dick for from the sardines.
You're like,
Holy Shit.
I'd often sucking Dick would be
moist.
That don't have water.
You're barely feeling the teeth.
Oh,
careful Mr Golfing.
You could fuck him and he can take you for a ride.
You know,
giving you a gentle dolphin,
blowjob,
but those giant in scissors,
all the crazy people on this planet.
You know there's one fucking
dude that worked at seaworld.
Tried to let the dog and suck his dick.
Come on.
There's got to be one or two.
I think by the time I was 2011 all you have to do is think about it.
If you think about it and say,
we think someone's ever fucked a dolphin apps,
a fucking,
if you can think about it,
it's been done a thousand times.
Do a youtube video of that.
That'd be amazing.
Well,
they would pull it down.
Those pussies,
they'd have to put it on foreign.
Highly emotion
beastiality you would have would happen.
That's illegal,
right?
Have to be hosted in another country.
It would have to,
it's illegal.
Can Fbi come to your house if you're watching animals?
Get Jack.
Well I don't,
I think federally it's illegal,
but statewise he did.
The weird thing with state's laws is that's how that movies got made.
In some states it's still legal.
The fuck animal and let animals,
dude,
can you imagine getting busted by the FBI for having all this like beastiality
porn.
But um,
but like how many guys out there were like fighting it?
Like this was a joke.
This made me laugh.
I wasn't into it.
All the people that downloaded it,
I don't,
yeah,
like they don't think you go to jail.
If you download it,
you go to jail.
If you put it online and have it on a wall,
if you downloaded it,
I'm going to jail because you can always say,
man,
your honor.
We went thought this was hilarious.
My buddies are watching all the time when I laughing.
I don't think as long as it's a victimless crime,
as long as it's looks like it's a grown adult,
I don't think that you get in trouble for that.
I think it's,
you're not,
you're not supposed to be in possession of it,
but I don't think you would ask that.
There's gotta be a website,
like who?
Like who,
you know,
if you think you fucked like the craziest,
weirdest creature,
put it online and have a judge and probably us.
It's got to be a contest.
Like fucking every single breed of dog or the wildest animal.
If you can get up on his polar bear,
you know,
anytime you figure it out and me tag,
there's any sort of a controversial thing like this.
The FBI will infiltrate these fucking dude.
Dude can't imagine if they want to fuck animal.
It's like,
well,
you know it,
you know?
Right.
When the dice going to sneak out and there's a donkey freeze,
FBI motherfucker,
you got me this donkey.
It's like an American idol thing so you could fuck the craziest animal.
What are you talking about?
[inaudible] what do you think about setups like that?
Like dogs wouldn't even be in the ballpark here.
Then people would get into like try to get bears and shit.
You know what I mean?
The oddest ones.
Trying to get like a hippopotamus
rope around his neck due to there was a $5 million grant,
American idol prize seek or [inaudible] video,
$5 million we would need is a couple of nuclear meltdowns in this country.
Lower,
lower the price of life.
And then for sure that could be a real show.
It can fuck the craziest animal next on spike after the top 196 top season 196
because you know what,
that is still the UFC heavyweight champion.
Cause now they have genetic engineering and he's fucking 200 years old.
But take the first year during a Koala bear,
first year they wouldn't get the crazy wild animal.
They have to build it.
They'd have to build like by the third and fourth season.
You know what I,
they're getting crazier and crazier.
Like the craziest would be like a fucking killer whale.
So realistically,
realistically there's not much difference between the human beings have today
and the human beings that we're having people fight tigers in the Roman empire
were the same fucking people.
The only thing is that we've managed to not have a giant natural disaster
between then and now.
So we've accumulated a bunch of data on how you shouldn't act.
That's the only reason why we don't have people fighting tigers in the middle of
a fucking arena today.
Cause if somebody put it out today,
we would,
there would be a bunch of people that would be into it.
And if anything ever happened to the people today,
if there was some fucking asteroid impact that killed off half of us and that
people survive,
it was all fucking chaos and may for sure within a hundred years people would be
fighting tigers in a,
in an arena.
Again,
it would start all over again.
When,
what year did they get that bad?
How did that come about?
Cause they had,
they had to come a point in time where they're like,
dude,
we can't be having it all died off.
You know,
the empire died off it.
That's the,
that was the,
I mean I think probably today somewhere,
if you've got enough money you can get a dude to fight a tiger.
You know,
I think I was at,
was it the fall of the Roman Empire?
Yeah.
Definitely didn't have it.
They didn't like move it to Greece or I don't know what to England.
Why not?
I think the Romans were the ones who were into the Colosseum and all the,
the,
the crazy fights that they would set up.
They must have been gangster,
his family ever to take over.
You're the head of the Roman Empire.
You're the fucking emperor of the greatest emp,
like ancient empire.
The Romans dominated all.
They smashed everybody and you're the emperor.
You're having fucking orgies.
You're having people fight lions in front of you.
You know what I mean?
What that must have been like back then there was no internet,
no television,
and this guy was the king of Rome by the ampere Everwell board as fuck.
Stand up and he would fucking give speeches to the death.
Was the words thousands of men raising their spears cheering for you.
I bet that had something to do with getting elected like this motherfucker.
He comes with the crazy shit.
At first it was the gladiators fighting each other that animals fighting
animals.
Then guys fighting animals.
It's like that was like a new campaign to get.
Uh,
and I think the whole royalty thing probably all started off because everybody
wants to think that they're the man.
Everybody wants to think that you know,
they could be the guy running shit.
If you think you're around like a regular dude,
you like,
this dude isn't better than me.
I could be better than that guy.
That's like the classic male ego problem.
But if you get someone who's elevated to the point of royalty,
like you can't even question,
you can't get to know them.
You are not allowed to get to know them so you never get the crack the puzzle.
He can't be sitting right next to him going,
this mother fucker's crazy.
You're running shit.
Why are you running shit?
Hey,
have your buddy get over here,
this guy,
we'll call him the king.
This guy's a crazy ass hall.
This guy's banging his daughters and he's fucking killing people for a goof and
having his wives executed.
He's crazy.
We've got to stop letting him run.
Shit we get,
he's just a regular person,
you know,
but they never got a chance to say he's just a regular person.
You can get close to him.
That's the only way a person can really rule.
They have to rule as if there's something outside of the human race.
They have to rule a deity.
Do you have to rule like there a god they have to rule like there you can't even
come close to them.
You got to get on your knees sire.
Thank you for hearing my words.
You know you had to get on your knees and not make eye contact with him and then
when he put his hand out you would kiss it.
What the fuck?
It's like they,
they,
you had to have that trick to keep,
to keep an empire together.
You couldn't just be,
couldn't have access to information.
It's like the ultimate example of how like those empires,
like the more access to information,
the more you realize that the guy in charge,
it's just fucking crazy.
The less likely it is to be able to have something like that.
That's why all these fucking empires are falling apart all over the world,
man.
That's what Egypt,
why?
What's going on in Egypt where Mubarak and while in Libya they're trying to get
rid of Qaddafi.
I mean I'm sure there's a bunch of American black ops involved as well.
There's a bunch of CIA shit that you know,
forcing these people out because they're probably sitting on a giant pool of
oil.
You know what I have into it because information,
because they're getting information.
I haven't listened to the Alex Jones version of what's going on in a and M
Libya.
I'm sure there's a whole different version.
I'm very interested in.
I just haven't had time.
Alex.
I haven't heard it either.
I haven't heard either.
I can't.
When shit is really happening,
when real shit has gone down.
That's the last time I want to listen to Alex cause he'll get you distracted.
It's eugenics.
What they're doing right now is they've got blood but FEMA has black plastic
coffins outside of Dallas.
I've seen them,
ladies and gentlemen,
I have the photographs and there's 200 billion of them.
They know there's not even 200 billion people,
so that's,
we're talking clones now.
Clones of people life extension.
We'll be right back by gold.
You need to buy gold ladies and gentlemen,
2012 solar impact.
Gold will protect you.
I like that load.
We will be right back right back.
That was good.
That's what he does.
We'll be right back.
Folks that's slick and run the show.
He's out of his fucking mind.
Alex Jones roles.
He's awesome.
But he's out of his mind.
He's a,
I think Alex Jones is dead on the money like 70% of the time.
That's what scares the shit out of me.
All the crazy stuff that he throws in there.
I mean maybe he's right.
I don't know.
It seems crazy in Maine,
but the real stuff that he's dead on the money about,
it's,
it's almost cheapened by all the other,
the,
the Histrionics,
the craziness.
He knew what the,
with the Japan thing,
he knew about those explosions like days before they would announce them.
They were not admitting shit.
He would get shit like somehow it could have been the lucky guy.
Let reactor four just blew out of that.
Damn.
I'm,
I got a one in six chance.
Oh Shit for him.
Yeah,
that's fine.
Alex,
you did it.
Well,
he,
he's a fucking news junkie and he has access to shit that other people don't
know why he's still alive.
How come they haven't tried to kill him?
So powerful,
man.
You don't even look.
You don't have to kill him for what?
He's not stopping anything.
No one's stopping anything.
And you know what things,
the things that get exposed,
they're supposed to get exposed.
He's like the Perez Hilton of the fucking,
the,
the political world.
That's what it is.
It's like,
you know,
he's exposing shit that,
you know what you fucked up anyway.
He shouldn't
have been doing it this way anyway.
Stupid.
You know,
you know this is wrong and everybody has in government,
it's not like everybody's evil in government,
but there's a lot of fucking stupid poor choices that get made and the better
they get exposed,
the better it is for everybody.
Even the people that are governing the people they need to be checked too.
It's not like everybody in government is evil.
They have to be evil.
They don't necessarily have to be evil.
A lot of people go into government with good intentions,
but along the way that gets stifled by corruption and bullshit.
So this is all good for everybody.
This is good for everybody when shit like this happens,
but the,
some of the stuff that he says is terrifying.
Like one thing that got passed by everybody that you never hear discuss was
during the World Trade Organization meetings in Seattle.
You remember those where the people were stopped from protesting.
This is what happened.
There was peaceful protests.
It was a long time ago.
I think it was like,
I want to say 2001 but I'm just throwing out numbers at my house.
I just pulled that out of my ass.
I think it was actually before that.
No,
it was before that because it was before nine 11 it was quite a bit where that
was.
The protesters were actually CIA guys.
Yeah.
Well the protesters were,
were cops.
They were there were paid anarchists,
they were people that were sent in to go in and cause chaos and break windows
and SMA and they will warm ski masks and they all wore military issue boots and
they weren't,
nobody knew them.
They weren't involved in the,
the rest of the protest.
The protest was peaceful and inconvenient because all these foreign delegates
and all these people were coming,
you know,
these are these representatives of foreign foreign countries.
We're coming to that one place and to have all this protest around was
embarrassing.
And it was disturbing and it was causing,
it was,
you know,
causing a lot of press.
Like they were having to answer a lot of questions about it.
So they turned it into a violent display.
They turned it into a vibey and they being the government,
they came in with guys that were in military outfits and they would wear ski
masks on and they broke windows and they smashed them.
And Alex Jones documents every single aspect of it,
including these guys going into a safe house and being allowed to,
uh,
to negotiate eventually all being released.
May he documents all of this and you know,
he does it with news reports and he does it with,
with video footage and it's pretty fucking crazy because what they did is they
shut down a protest.
They sent some fucking goons in and they shut down a protest and this isn't Nazi
Germany.
This is in the Roman empire.
This is the United States of America.
That's crazy.
It's fucking nuts.
And it's 100% it's not like this is a conspiracy theory.
They stopped people from walking through with things that said Wt.
Oh,
with a red line on it.
How fucking UNAMERICAN is that?
Anything's possible.
You're saying that you can't go in with a pin that says World Trade Organization
that you're opposed to it.
You can't have an opinion that's not even offensive.
It's not.
There's no swears,
no curse.
It's not something that would hurt children.
You know,
you just have a,
a WTO with a red line through and you're telling me I can't go to work.
They could do,
wouldn't let people into buildings.
They had cops there with guns.
There were telling people,
you have to take that shirt off,
you have to take that pin off and they have videos of this fucking America.
They dig,
created a no protest zone.
So just for the stuff like that that Alex exposes,
you know whether or not he's right about a missile hitting the or any of that
other
stuff.
Shit,
I don't know man.
It just not enough time in the world to be dwelling on all this shit.
He's right about enough.
He's wrong about a couple of things.
But if you're going to judge a guy based on like,
oh,
he was wrong about this,
so he can't know anything else.
You know that none of us would have any opinions that mattered.
He has fucked up a little bit here and there,
but man,
I believe the shit he tells me I believe I'm confident with in the 90
percentile.
I'm comfortable.
He's a fun guy too.
I enjoy his company.
He's a great guy.
Like I love hanging out with her.
Yeah,
it's pretty surreal hanging out on Alex Jones.
Right?
That's cool man.
We took him to Vegas when we took him to the UFC.
He were all hanging out,
having a good time.
You guys want,
I'm really happy.
Brought me out here to relax,
you know,
find a new world order,
man.
It's fucking crazy.
You know,
you hear not any to get a little crazy.
He's got a cigarette.
I love it.
I love it cause all he,
he loves talking about all the,
it's like he could go two ways.
You could be a guide.
Like please don't talk about conspiracies like any writer,
unless I was talking about normal city,
but no,
not Alex Jones.
He'll go,
Donald Rumsfeld was the one who,
he's the one who got that pass through to diet coke.
That's how it got in.
Yeah.
Okay.
I feel bad for that stuff and to calm down,
but he does hurt but does doesn't it?
That's him.
Yeah.
Let let him,
you know,
you let you let him be him.
Could you imagine if they made the Brian Red Band conspiracy show?
You'd be like,
hey guys.
I mean,
who knows?
I don't know.
You know,
why are we fucking freaking out about this?
All right.
We'll be right back after these words for the fleshlight.
That'd be the Brian Red van conspiracy radio show.
He'd be like,
I think we're all getting a little carried away here.
Okay.
We don't know shit.
I don't know what's happening in Japan.
That's way the fuck over there.
Forget it.
God.
Everybody relaxed.
That's you.
Fema has 300,000 helicopters with beds and I'm ready to go.
They can stay in the air for up to three days.
Okay.
Solar charged helicopters in case of an asteroid will impact.
It's recommended that that he'll fucking,
they'll just fill your brain up every day with more information about doom and
the apocalypse.
I love it.
I have so many questions he has answers to all.
My craziest thing is he's always selling gold.
I think that motherfucker just needs to step up and start selling gasoline and
bullets.
Stop fucking around with this gold cause you know,
if some shit goes down,
Gold's going to be useless.
All right?
Unless the Annunaki land again and we've got to give them gold to let them take
us aboard the UFO.
And unless that happens,
Gold's going to be used.
Gold is like,
gee,
it's universal no matter what.
And Mad Max Times gold is still going to be really,
yeah,
I think it is.
No matter what.
That's the one thing we all agree on in this plant.
We don't agree on Shit.
Every country,
even the same religion,
it all depends on whether or not by the time the apocalypse hits,
we've created artificial people.
If we created like,
like whores artificial whores,
you know soulless,
mindless robot whores that you could just fuck the shit out of you and they're
so happy and they just shut off and wait for you to come back and when you come
back they talk to you perfectly nearly.
It's like it's just like blade runner except they don't have a soul.
Why would they shut up?
They should be cleaning my house.
And you've got one of those too,
Bro.
You got to,
you got one.
You got this crazy looking Tongan woman with face tattoos.
She cleans your house slash.
Body,
but gee,
I wish you could.
Can you fuck that robot?
No,
no.
You better off getting a dude house robot with no Dick,
a unit and unit.
He's built like he's built like the incredible hug downstairs.
It's like Ken,
I'm never going to have a guy's face is all fucked up.
It's just one.
I like one big cycle.
I was like,
there's no way to let girls know he's got three eyes.
He's got three eyes because you don't get to see everywhere so he could protect
you.
Imagine went in the first eight years to be your protector.
That's when technology ends.
Cause all the guys build in this shit.
They're going to have harems.
You think about the nerds of the world that going to have like 10 chicks around
them at all time.
They're going to be going on date after date after date for monkeys.
Who?
What monkey would ever think about having a pet dog.
They'd be like,
what the fuck he talking about?
You can't trust a dog.
They're going to kill you,
man.
You can't have a fucking pet duck.
How are you going to be able to control a dog?
Well,
when humans evolved to a certain point,
we'll be able to have like pet things that we've created.
Like pet monsters,
like pet,
like your,
your house will be guarded by like superheroes.
Like juggernaut will guard your house,
you'll have your own genetically engineered man.
Way better than a robot.
Fuck on.
Never sleeps.
Robotic Trump
leaps over buildings and plans on shit trying to break into my house.
Bitch,
superheroes,
gardeners,
you crack head crack head with a screwdriver.
You're going to get past the superhero.
Yeah.
Well I am so fascinated by what the fuck ever is going to happen when,
when things keep going.
You know,
I watch all those ray Kurt's wheel lectures and I've read some of his papers and
some of his articles about the singularity and the idea of artificial
intelligence and it's all going to happen.
We're not going to stop.
I mean we,
we've created so much between now and just a couple hundred years ago.
The difference between our life now and like I was watching the unforgiven the
other day on a plane.
Still bad ass bro.
Still bad ass from like 1990 whatever the fuck it was.
That movie is awesome.
The Clint Eastwood is the Shit,
especially in that movie.
That's the best western movie ever,
but I looked at the way these fucking people were living in.
I'm like,
my God,
that's less than 200 years ago.
Less than 200 years ago and they're riding horses and getting rained on and shit
and they're going to these places and the houses are made a wooden,
they're leaking like crazy because of the rain.
They didn't even know how to make rooves right back then.
It's just this just too,
you know,
that's probably also just like dramatic scenes in a movie,
don't you think back then if you had a leaky roof,
like you'd be on that thing,
you know in Hackman and not gene Hackman,
the sheriff,
he didn't know what the fuck is nothing else to do and they get working internet
to fucking bother.
He's like,
oh,
I have a leaky roof.
Ios right now going to tell us part of the character development of Gene Hackman
who supposed to be incompetent but yet cocky and that was the whole reason why
it was so satisfying.
The cleanness would killed him in the end.
Okay Dude,
I know,
I know.
We're just having fun here.
You fucks.
You would.
Wouldn't you think that like Mcdonald Douglas or like one of those come a Hughes
aircraft for some would be like involved in the number one product on the planet
would be like a real person that you could find control you control.
That would be the ultimate robot that looked the best robot would look exactly
human.
Could you imagine if you had just,
you know you had a robot woman in your house and you come home and your wife
like lit it on fire.
It was fucking it.
Oh yeah,
she's having a year asshole he'd come in with was fucking robots.
Press tanks.
We've got to change shit shitting and that thing's mouth while you're at work,
you come,
well she's coughing and your robots coughing and choking and she got shit caked
in her mouth.
Like what the fuck have you been doing?
I shit in her mouth.
Can you imagine the first robots and robot horn?
My house,
I'm going to shit in her mouth every day.
You wouldn't even feel bad cause it's not a real person.
You know,
if you were shitting in like your slaves mouth,
you'd be like,
wow,
that's kinda rude.
But dudes,
dudes get transvestite robots.
Oh Shit.
You know what I read the other day that's,
I need to verify this.
Of course.
Cause every time I don't verify something that I've read,
people go corrupt,
there's information,
I get somebody angry,
tweets,
relax,
everybody would lax.
But this is what I read that more people are in the sex slaves today than were
slaves back when slavery was legal.
How crazy is that?
My second one of those numbers,
the more people are sex late,
we should,
we could sue should.
That's one of those numbers too is like,
how the fuck did they know?
Yeah,
right.
You know,
I mean,
sex slaves live in basements and they can only come out when they,
they're hungry for cock.
You know,
it's like,
who counts that guy?
Or they just guesstimating that f every block that sex they figure out.
I think they do it the same way they do about,
um,
Mexicans just take a wild guess.
They don't know.
You know,
I go,
no,
they don't have any idea.
They have no idea how many Mexicans or there's just sneaking in here,
left and right.
My Gardener,
I shouldn't say this,
I can't,
I can't ride them out.
You know,
I've got a cool house gardener and he knows a bunch of illegals.
He's legal himself,
but he knows a bunch of illegals.
He's got some great stories about dude's going back and forth and it took him a
few tries,
but he came back.
They don't know.
Man.
This dude's going back and forth is a fucking three guys in Arizona with white
pickup trucks trying to guard a million miles of fence.
Good luck boys.
You're on your own.
Good luck.
You know how many fucking Mexicans get through there and it's crazy.
A lot of them do.
It came to this country illegally.
He snuck over the border.
How became the last?
It was dad's store.
He walked all the way to like Sacramento twice.
That's craziness.
That was picking grapes I think it was.
It was actually a Oxnard or something like that.
That's a lot of mother fucking walk all fucked up.
He's apparently all fucked up.
Yeah.
I think maybe took rides everywhere.
They watched it.
They had some one show.
They watched his family sneak across the border and they followed them from
sneaking across the border to trying to get someone to take them in in Phoenix.
They were trying to get someone to let them sleep in the garage for the night
because they had just snuck in and now people like,
man,
you can't be here,
you can't be here.
Like,
and they were talking Spanish to them.
It was really crazy.
It was like these Mexicans that had had snuck through did not want these guys
that hadn't to be staying in the garage.
They just wanted a place to sleep for the night before they,
uh,
they manage to town and they were like,
they were literally like going into knocking on people's doors,
can you help us?
They didn't have anything.
He had no food.
They had no money.
Like wow,
you talk about taking chances and it was really moving man.
Like this couple,
this man,
this woman there holding hands and they're,
they're trying to get across to America and try to get jobs and they're,
you know,
talking to them in Spanish about,
what they're looking forward to when they go into America and you know,
trying to make some money and they're going to send money back home.
And it's like Whoa,
this is like why can't they just come over?
What the fuck is that?
And you know,
why can't they just come over here?
You know,
can't we just like have like a screening process to see who's nice and if
they're nice,
let him over here.
Cause every definitely road would have been no borders.
Every place was the exact same.
It just seems,
I mean,
people will get crazy cousin,
bro.
That's chaos.
There's a reason why there's borders.
The reason one is border patrol.
They're there to protect you.
You can't have no rules.
You fucking hit beats the old fucking he.
Yeah,
but if everybody was nice,
wouldn't it be possible to have no borders,
right?
Yeah.
What the fuck is keeping it?
You know,
that's,
that's the real issue at hand.
It's not more borders.
It's like how do you make everybody nice?
How do you,
how do you smooth it all out?
That's the real issue.
It's not borders.
There's gotta be a map that you can get before you make the trip.
Like a map of all the home depots and all the strawberry fields he's got to go
to.
Did you change,
move,
move forward?
So you're actually talking into the microphone.
That's why he had to turn it up.
There's got to be a map of what?
Pump up the volume.
Be Valuable.
A map with all the home depots and all the strawberry fields in southern
California,
right?
Like one of those maps,
the stars like cause you that you're going to get a job for sure.
You show up to a strawberry field,
they're going to give you like 20 bucks or something.
You're for sure going to get work done.
That's the bottom of the barrel.
How crazy are those maps,
those stars?
Those are so disgusting,
man.
When you,
you,
you see some dude sitting there with a,
uh,
like a pile of names.
Hey,
this is where this guy lives.
Go fuck with him.
This is where that guy lives.
Go stare at him while he's sleeping.
Have you ever done one of those?
No.
That's so crazy.
So creepy.
It's like,
what are these guys thinking?
They're like,
you know,
handing out like free stalker guides.
Like this is the easy way to find where someone lives.
How easy is it to just make shit up?
Yeah.
Fucking a Neil diamond lives in that fucking house and a fucking Brad Pitt and
Angelina.
They're fucking crazy.
They're fucking right now.
The crazy.
They steal each other's blood.
Just wait for them.
They love their fans.
Like how would you go?
It's like how would you know they love their families.
There are certain,
there are certain types of people that would,
you know,
they're catering to the same people that would buy that fake weed that you see
in like high times.
You met.
That was always the most disappointing shit ever.
High Times.
They would always,
you know,
be down for legalization is down.
Meanwhile you're selling fake weed.
You're ripping people off,
man.
Those are the sponsors.
Yeah,
but so what you,
your sponsors a crook.
You don't have a problem with your sponsor only praying on retards.
I mean that's what the sponsor did.
You,
if you bought that stuff,
you had to be like a 10 year old boy or retarded person to be something wrong
with you.
But Dude said that that's how high times survives is with our money because it's
like every other page.
There's like,
I refuse to admit or refuse to believe that in a nation of 300 million and who
knows how many pot smokers is there?
30 million of us,
let's say 30 million pot smokers in this country.
I refuse to believe that you couldn't produce a quality magazine.
That was interesting and then had to do with people who smoked pot,
who a engage in different activities and show how much marijuana enhances their
life instead of the same old stupid shit that they have in those magazines.
Every week,
every week there's a girl in a bikini and she's got a button or hand.
Whoa,
look at the bud.
It's crazy.
And look at the fucking look at the picture in the middle.
Amazing.
We have a picture of the bud.
You're not saying anything different.
It's all the same God Damn Shit and magazine industry so dead now.
That's the reason why they have to sell this fucking fake weed shit.
That fake weed shit is insulting you.
If that is like,
you know,
you're,
you're allowing someone to steal from your fans.
You're allowing someone that's like,
that's like if I had this thing and if the fleshlight and you know,
wasn't our sponsor and I decided to get some other be like big Dick Pills,
you know,
of big dig and man,
what a hypocrite.
What a creepy person I would be if I was allowing these people to get ripped off
by something.
You know,
allowing,
I was promoting something.
That's what they're doing,
man.
They've got pages of this shit,
these fake fucking buds.
And you ever tried that Dee Zee?
No,
I haven't tried.
I've heard it actually works the fuck out of here.
That shit doesn't work.
I actually know the stuff that k two stuff that they made illegal,
that stuff works.
But that shit they've been selling in high times.
Yo.
That's the shit they smoke in movies,
man.
That's the shit that Mitch Hedberg smoked with.
Peter Frampton.
Remember that joke?
You remember that joke?
Mitch Hedberg Dude,
he goes,
how does it Mitch Hepberg doing it?
He goes,
um,
once smoked fake pot in a movie with Peter Frampton,
he goes,
that's way better than smoking a real pot with a dude who looks like Peter.
I'd done that way more times.
I can match low.
He was awesome,
man.
He was amazing.
That's a guy that,
man,
when he died,
I went shit like that.
That really was like,
God damn it.
We lost a good one.
So you know,
it's so fucking weird about you saying that whole entire story.
The person that told me last that that shit worked and she was his ex.
Oh,
willin then.
Well maybe she was talking about that k two stuff.
That stuff's real legit.
How weird is that?
This is recently a yet.
It was like a month ago.
Guarantee you.
She's talking about the,
the synthetic marijuana,
which does work,
that stuff.
They're making it illegal everywhere because it does work.
They've just modified it somehow or another so that it's not technically the
same thing as marijuana.
It just becomes the,
you know,
they can do that.
That's what they also did with those bath salts things.
Remember we thought it was bath salts,
but it really was,
is they were selling it as bad so they could sell it,
but it really was just amphetamines.
You know,
they can change the chemical components of something and make it something
that's not classified,
like,
you know,
oh well here's this new thing.
What is this?
This isn't even illegal.
And so that's why they have,
they have also like some,
some laws in certain places where things become illegal if they're related or
you know,
to other things being illegal.
So that's why a five Meo DMT was never classified as a schedule one,
but it's the most potent form of DMT.
And you used to be able to buy it online.
Man used to be able to go to American chemical company,
all these different places and just by DMT online.
But then,
uh,
because it's up like related to nn Dmt,
which is illegal.
They made it illegal and they stopped people from selling it online and they
made them very aware that there were consequences,
even though it's not technically an illegal substance.
So what would happen if you got arrested in for it?
I don't know.
It's tricky.
You'd be able to fight it.
Probably.
See the real thing with all these schedules,
schedule one substances is the last thing they want is scrutiny.
They want anybody looking at them.
They don't want to make a new one illegal because then people start looking at
what,
what makes it illegal and what is legal?
And then the argument comes up,
well how can that be illegal when this is legal and that's illegal and this is
sold at every pharmaceutical company all across the country.
It's been shown to be incredibly addictive and this destroys your liver.
But doctors prescribed it like candy,
you know,
w it would open up the doors of scrutiny.
So what day would rather do is threatened people close all these companies down
there selling all this shit and not change any of the laws.
Just go,
Hey,
shut the fuck up.
Sit the fuck down.
This is the government here.
And that's what they do because they don't want everybody looking at it.
Because if you look at it at a certain point in time when you're a grown man,
I am a 43 year old grown man.
Okay.
And if another grown man my age or God forbid,
even younger is telling me what I can and can't do with my body,
that doesn't hurt anybody and they don't even have research to back it up.
It's not like I saw that movie limitless the other day.
Pretty fucking interesting move.
Is that the one where he opens up his mind?
Yes.
He uses a,
it's a Bradley Cooper movie.
I didn't enjoy the end.
Spoiler alert.
It's Calgary or affects the MDR.
Pretty sweet.
Thought the end was wack.
[inaudible] was like,
oh,
he's awesome all the time now.
Sorry,
the end.
I win.
You lose.
There was so stupid.
We're that sucker punch you gotta hold on,
but hold on a second.
But um,
the,
the thing about that is that there were massive consequences.
Like he like he would like lose time.
Like it,
it became got,
people were dying from it.
It wasn't just as simple as you take this thing,
it accelerates you and then you just live like an awesome person for the rest of
your life.
There's,
there's consequences.
Now if you can't prove consequences,
then you have zero argument.
And that's the real argument.
The real problem with psychedelic drugs being illegal.
You have all these people saying that they've helped them.
All these people that are going and taking that,
I began like ed clay,
our friend Ed clay,
who changed his life,
changed who he is,
you know,
and became this really fucking warm,
open person after going on this,
these ibogaine retreats and that's illegal.
Why is it illegal?
There's no,
there's no sh there's no studies showing it harms you.
There's only studies showing that people have benefited from it and so many
people talk about it glowingly and yet you have other grown adults telling you
what you can and can't experience.
Then there's same ages you,
that's ridiculous.
That's nonsense.
There's,
there's a,
a lack of reality and a lack of,
of openness when it comes to discussing these things.
These things are never discussed and you know,
in,
in politics,
these are huge issues.
The issues of being able to control your consciousness is a giant issue and the
fact that that's not discussed ever during presidential campaigns shows how
infant tile we are,
at the very least.
Occasionally it gets breached.
Mr. Obama,
did you ever smoke marijuana?
And if so,
did you inhale you?
I'm sorry dude.
I thought that was the point hall.
That's it.
That's the,
the in depth version of the discussion on marijuana.
Obama admits to smoking marijuana and inhaling says that was the point.
Amazing.
Oh,
and everybody,
it's like we're little children.
It's like as a nation and in our entirety we have the attitude about drugs,
about marijuana,
about psychedelics that an 11 year old has.
That's how we treat it.
Like,
oh,
what are you doing with that?
What are you doing with that boy?
Yeah,
it's,
we're little.
We're a little fucking children.
It's one of the biggest issues I think as far as consciousness goes,
that is in the world.
One of the number one issues,
the ability to control your consciousness,
the ability to seek personal evolution through psychedelic experience.
These,
these are huge issues.
These are issues that are radically transformed.
You,
radically transformed me,
radically transformed you.
You,
you,
we've all been transformed by psychedelic experience.
Guy Named Kelly Mullis who want to noble Nobel Peace Prize or uh,
I guess it is a Nobel peace prize for,
um,
work in DNA,
uh,
discover no science.
Nobel science.
Yeah.
He was the guy who founded on LSD,
right?
Yes,
yes,
exactly.
He did it while he was fucked up on it.
But yeah,
I don't remember what the,
uh,
the,
the finding was,
but that guy actually is a bad example because idea turned crazy when he got
older.
Really?
Yeah.
Became like real belligerent,
getting crazy arguments with people and became a nutcase.
He has a lot of weird stuff about it.
Another interesting one is Francis Crick,
Francis Crick apparently,
and this is all hearsay because uh,
you know,
the article says very explicitly that Francis Crick told this man that if he
printed a word of this,
he would sue when they printed it obviously after quick died.
But Crick,
the guy who,
um,
he said that he came up with the idea of the double helix for DNA while he was
on acid.
But again,
this is a guy who says that Crick said that the problem is with anything like
that,
I said,
people are full of Shit.
Why would they lie?
I don't know.
But they could have and they do a lot.
You know,
people fucking lie like crazy man.
We were talking about that a game show in my head episode that I did,
I told you about this shit when we had people,
uh,
talk about Ufo shows on video.
We had a pretend news
camera and start talking about this is done.
This is what we did.
The game show in my head was a fun ass show.
And what was interesting about it was there was a contestant and I had a
microphone and I would talk in their ear with a little earpiece and I would tell
them,
here's your stunt.
This is what you got to do.
They didn't know what was going to happen.
They didn't know where they were.
We had them in a van and then we would open the door and say,
walk to that mark on the floor and then Joe will be talking to you in your ear.
So they would walk to that mark.
I go,
all right dude,
you ready to do this?
He goes,
yeah,
here's what we got.
You are a news reporter.
Okay.
There was just a Ufo sighting right here in Hollywood.
It was huge.
A giant flying saucer was here and it took off.
Now you lost your witness.
The witness was going to go on camera and he was going to tell everybody about
this Ufo experience and now you're going to look really stupid because you've
got the camera here and there's no witness,
so you're going to try to ask one of these people to pretend it was them in you.
That was their stunt and every person that got to do it,
if they,
I think if they got three people to do it,
they won 5,000 bucks.
That's awesome,
dude.
People did it instantly.
They did it instantly.
They started goes,
hey,
I wonder if you could do me a favor.
Those UFL here earlier,
apparently some people saw it and it was witnesses,
but I guess they chicken down with a camera's here.
Like,
I don't know what to do.
I mean,
do you think you could pretend that it was you?
Yeah,
man.
Yeah.
You can be on a TV right now.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
And you would,
people would just start talking.
What happened?
Oh Man.
It was a black bright light and in an an an an an.
Then a Ufo came and I just started talking.
It was incredible.
We were all sitting in the truck,
what was happening?
We were shaking our heads going,
wow,
how full of shit or people,
people would just start talking about shit.
So that was my point.
I mean it's like,
I don't know if Francis Crick story about DNA was true.
Yeah.
It was a lot of fun man.
You were,
you were talking earlier about Ed clay.
Yeah.
The way it changed his life.
Ed Clay was a very successful entrepreneur who got their smart guy,
great guy who got very driven and you know,
he did Jujitsu.
He had a,
he has an MMA academy.
He was always hurt.
So like a lot of it and they athletes,
he got addicted to pills.
He got,
it was really bad.
It really was,
was a fucking up his life in a big way.
He heard about Ibogaine and Ibogaine is like the African version of DMT in a
nutshell.
And what I will gain does Iowasca apparently a curious alcoholism and Ibogaine
cures in,
in,
in a high percentage rate.
Uh,
I've a gang cures addiction,
a certain pills.
And Ed clay heard about it.
He went to,
it's illegal in the United States.
He went to Mexico.
There's this Ibogaine retreat in Mexico,
in this city that they're all trippers and they've all done Ibogaine and they've
done the Iowasca all of them.
And it's just like a city where there's music always said there was music 24
hours,
you land in Mexico City,
you drive four hours,
you're in this village and everyone's playing music.
There's artists everywhere.
There's music constantly was 24,
seven.
You hear people like singing and dancing and there's music and,
and uh,
he,
he went to this place,
he did the Ibogaine treatment,
which takes,
it takes you on a trip.
It's like Iowasca that lasts like two days or something like that last for a
long time.
And it's,
um,
it's,
you know,
you get to see yourself and you get to see the world for what it is.
And what it does is somehow it does something to your brain receptors or
something.
It's a realization of who you really are.
And it resets your receptors in some weird way.
I don't know the details,
but it changed his life.
He came back to the states.
So it said as receptors.
As far as addictions,
yes,
yes.
And it's not just a psychological healing.
It's actually a physical healing and actually,
exactly.
Wow.
That's incredible.
He changes.
I mean he is.
How many people is I work on?
Do you know?
He's dedicated.
It's a high percent.
It's like 80% he dedicated his life to I will gain and all the money that he's
had from other businesses.
He sold one of his businesses,
a big MMA company.
He sold it and he's dedicated his whole life to saving as many people from
addiction of pills as possible.
Amazing that we have this issue in this country where that thing which is so
helpful is illegal and these things that are so damaging and so scary,
our legal,
and they lied about how addictive they are and when they got them through,
when they made fucking Oxycontin's legal,
there's a,
there's a bunch of documents that show that they weren't being honest about the
possibility of addiction.
That stuffs heroin,
man,
that stuff gets so many of my friend,
I don't want to say his name because I don't want to be public about it,
but someone,
someone I know very recently died of it.
He had a pill problem.
Hello.
You know,
and it's,
it's scary shit man.
You know,
I've,
I've known people that,
uh,
immediately became a pill.
Zombies I've known,
I've known to people very well and it became pills on bees while I knew them.
And um,
some scary shit,
man.
Scary that the government doesn't stop.
That if you're out there and you have a pill problem or you know,
somebody that has a pill problem look into Ibogaine Ibo,
g a.
I.
N.
E I think I will gain ed clay.
If you look him up.
He's,
he'll,
he's doing everything he can to help as many people as possible.
I mean,
you know,
it's really funny that I will gain was the drug that got hunter s Thompson and
uh,
in trouble when he was a journalist,
when he was covering the hunters Thompson was to fucking genius writer and such
an interesting guy.
And what he did was he was covering the elections.
I'm like 1970 something,
whatever the fuck it was.
And he just decided to start making shit up.
So he started making shit up about these candidates.
And one of the things that he said was that Ed ed muskie brought in a Brazilian
doctor and because he's addicted to Ibogaine and he shows like all the,
uh,
the symptoms of Ibogaine addiction and he put the shit in,
this is printed in the rolling stone.
So everybody thought this was real.
Everybody thought to.
So they started asking him about,
and I slowly started breaking down.
The guy started going crazy publicly,
like the pressure got to him and he would give these public speeches and
everybody would be accusing him of being on some crazy drug.
And so hunter is Tom Chan,
like literally drove this guy insane by writing that he was on drugs.
The guy,
there's video of the guy again,
the movie
Gonzo,
you see the V,
there's video of the guy like breaking down at a campaign speech.
Just lose his mind.
It was Ibogaine.
That's what a Thompson had said that he was addicted to.
And then another guy was addicted to see made up a name of speed called wallet,
some exotic brand of speed.
Then you're fucking running for president back in the 70s.
And that shit happens.
You know,
you get this crazy ass asshole just making shit up about you.
And there was no internet,
there was no nothing.
You couldn't,
you couldn't go on TV and talk about it.
And it was really funny,
man.
It's fucking interesting shit.
He goes,
well I didn't lie.
uh,
there was uh,
there was a rumor going around Milwaukee that uh,
he was addicted to Ibogaine and I,
I was one who started the rumor.
It's like,
all I said was there was a rumor.
He goes,
I was actually pretty factual or described it.
It's very funny,
man.
Did you see a sucker punch at all?
Not yet heard.
It's awesome though.
It looks pretty bad ass.
Like,
you know what?
You see it.
Did you see it?
No,
I haven't seen it,
but I only saw,
I guess the,
the teaser preview in the past.
I just don't like the real preview.
Holy Shit.
I never saw the whole preview.
You go to see that movie and you're not stoned.
You should go to jail.
Why is it movie night in Three d though?
It's that.
That's why I'm pissed.
It's not,
I don't think it's in three really?
Yeah,
it's an Imax,
but it's not an imax.
You know what,
man?
I gotta be honest.
The movie has to be super special for me to be into it in Three D.
I'm annoyed wearing those stupid glasses.
Those things don't bother me.
Really.
I liked the visuals.
I like the glass.
Google glass is bugged the shit out of me.
I don't know.
But you know,
I guess I shouldn't say that because then it doesn't beg me in every movie cause
an Avatar.
It was so spectacular that it didn't bug me.
I saw that on la and that was the biggest thing.
How has that
looked like?
It looked,
it looked like to me it was,
you know,
from the,
the,
the point of view of a bunch of marines fighting,
getting called to fight these aliens that landed on in La and they're fighting
them through La.
It looks like a video game.
Like infomercial kind of,
it looked like a trick.
It's like the plot was so gears of war four so bad.
The gears of war would have a way better plot.
Oh Man.
The way they got there,
the way they,
they won and they beat the aliens.
Don't even tell me
so bad.
It's just what we were talking about earlier,
the MMA movie,
this fast and furious.
The same thing.
There's a bunch of people,
Megan,
dumb ass movies.
But here's the reason why man,
this is what you don't realize.
Where I don't realize sometimes either.
I like to go on [inaudible] dot TV or mixed martial arts.com I love to go on
there cause it's,
it's a fun place to talk about Jujitsu and fighting and you know,
and talk about MMA and UFC shit.
But it's also fun to see how fucking dumb some of those people are.
One guy put a big post about movies or putting about mood.
Like when the expendables came out there were,
they were going off,
dudes were going off talking about how great the expendables was,
mixed martial arts.com they were going off about how great the expendables where
I thought this has to be ironic.
Like this has to be irony.
Like they couldn't have actually enjoyed this.
It was one look I like a good fucking blow them up moving more than anybody.
But that was one of the worst movies of all time and it was unbelievably bad.
And as I'm watching them,
when I call in a holy fuck is this bad?
But then I go online and you read people talking
about it and they're like,
just fucking emerge movie.
I'm going to sit again this weekend when my cousin and I'm like,
are they 15 or
yes.
Is that what it is?
You got to remember about age groups.
So like I keep on forgetting about this,
but half these people on Twitter that are to have the bad language skills and
stuff like that.
They're probably 12.
Yeah.
Cause if I was 12 I'd be talking shit nonstop all day long.
Very likely.
But anyway,
what was my point
about the guy that on the message board,
uh,
battle La.
Exactly.
And they were talking just about battle La the other day about how fucking
awesome it was.
Five stars,
amazing movie.
And then it was like four or five dudes would say that.
And I'd be like,
I'd be like squeezing my head together and go really real.
And then one guy would come on and go,
you guys are all retarded.
That movie sucked a million Cox,
you listen to it.
Yeah.
And I'll go back to the tech guys.
But that's also probably the guy that talks about shit about your music and
about my comedy.
You know,
the guys who were negative man,
they're,
they're not always right.
The negative all the time.
But when it comes to movies,
man,
it's very difficult to find like a good group that you agree with.
Everything,
dumbest aliens ever.
Once they got on the ground and they had like these,
these tall ass robot aliens like terminator don't wear like dom like you got you
will across the fucking galaxy and these guys are hiding behind a bus 20 yards
away from you and there's a scene that last five minutes and they're behind the
bus and all around in these aliens are fucking,
everybody up at your soldiers had like this little girl and the fucking cat and
they're like,
I'm like,
how long has this scene to aliens are still trying to walk?
They were totally retarded.
You know,
it looks really bad.
Is that knew Arthur remake.
Oh,
seen that preview of that.
It's just like the exact one.
Why would you remake that into,
it's just like they're just adding like,
oh,
an Xbox live
dude.
He's funny though.
I like Kim Man.
I liked him.
I like that.
Did you like get them to the Greek?
I did like that movie,
Dude.
He's going to like that movie.
There's a movie called the man from her character is one of the dumbest movies
that people have been recommended to me lately.
Oh,
there's a movie called the man from Earth about a guy who was a fucking cave man
who survived until today and he was Jesus.
And it's like a play.
Like they're over this guy's house.
He's leaving.
He has to leave cause he doesn't age and he doesn't want them all to get
suspicious.
So every 10 years he has to up and leave.
It is so bad.
It's so stupid and the acting is so dumb,
but yet all these fucking people,
what do you got to watch this?
It's amazing.
So fascinating.
So intriguing.
You know,
and like Mike,
how could you be intrigued by this dumb ass movie about a caveman who was Jesus
who is still alive today?
Really,
really?
Oh,
that's why he came back from the dead because he's like super,
he can't die.
He's like SUPERNAP.
Battleaxe had me for like 35 minutes to beginning.
The beginning of battle was good.
I was like,
fuck man.
That okay.
They're doing a good job.
20 minutes into it.
I'm like,
okay,
would that mean show the aliens?
Yet the ones they started fighting what?
The aliens,
they couldn't figure that one.
I like to make it realistic.
You really think that'd be a battle.
There's like these,
these marines that survived and they're finally pulling them out of the city,
La because they're going to nuke it.
They're going to new it.
We got out in time.
They're going to do new kit that goes off.
One do drops off.
He Goes,
I'm Colin's back when you go back and then another and then Michelle Rodriguez
comes down.
She,
because I'm going to go with you.
She wants him dead.
They're dropping them off the bat.
Some common kamikaze leg and they went four of them.
Four.
You know what sucks though?
Is that battle La on rotten tomatoes got like a 34% rotten tomatoes is a Saudi
accurate sucker punch 21
oh,
okay.
Fuck you.
I'm not going then I'll trust them.
That's the beautiful thing about the Internet man.
Back in the,
you still have to listen to Roger Ebert.
Roger Heber didn't like gladiator.
He didn't like the unforgettable,
it's like a bunch of movies that he didn't like that were fucking awesome.
Gladiator,
Huh?
Fuck do not like gladiator.
Yeah.
I would like to seek his top 10 dislikes that,
you know,
that ended up getting Oscars or something.
Yeah.
He got in a little hissy fit with a fucking Charlie Sheen online on Twitter.
It was interesting recently.
Yeah,
we were talking about it and one of the post fight video blog or the post
podcast video blogs,
it was like tr,
he wrote something about Charlie Sheen,
I could do what he's doing,
but then my wife would leave me and then,
uh,
Charlie,
you know,
and then I would be lonely and depressed just like him.
And He,
and he and Charlie writes back to Roger,
didn't even have five girls at the same time,
you know,
like along the lines of dining loan was stupid,
and I'm like,
I can't believe Roger Ebert is going after Charlie Sheen.
Like Roger Paper,
it's like almost dead.
He lost his jaw to cancer.
He can't talk,
he can't eat.
He has to eat through a tube and yet he's shitting on Charlie Sheen,
forgetting hookers and
whores.
Really Valley of the dolls.
What does that he's,
that's a movie they wrote that movie he wrote and it's all about dogs or like
corn chips,
isn't it?
Is it?
Who wrote it?
Roger Ebert.
Maybe he lives this whole different life.
We don't know.
And he's just some crazy old per he said.
He said it sucked.
I saw it that the due date movie.
Have you seen that yet?
I just came on TV.
I like Brody Stevens at the beginning of it.
Yeah.
Yup,
Yup.
That golf [inaudible] in anything.
That guy now I know.
He's so talented.
They don't even make him shaved.
The beard.
Yeah.
Every movie.
Ah,
no.
That's his look man.
I know they won't.
They don't helps and it helps though.
So good.
He's so good.
If he was a wreck,
we're going to need you to shave it for this character.
Well,
he made what makes him look like he's that strange guy
you hear about Brody Stevens also HBO has picked them up for a new TV show.
What is it?
Uh,
Zach Alpha and Hopkins is going to pretty much make a show about Brody,
like a documentary type thing.
Machiavellian.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
That's Brody Stevens blowing the fuck up.
Good for him.
Well,
Brody has always just needed someone to sort of like direct people to what he
does.
You know,
he's amazing.
he's a,
he's one of the funniest guys I know.
He's so interesting,
man.
He's such a fucking unusual dude.
He could talk about anything.
Okay.
And for whatever reason he's fascinating.
You know,
welfare.
I'll just,
the role of the office too.
I'm going to use that.
Let's,
I think that's only for like three episodes.
Oh,
is it?
Yeah,
I'm pretty sure.
Oh,
that guy's too fucking busy,
bro.
That's gonna say that.
That's awesome.
If he's doing that.
Yeah.
Gay.
I mean stupid.
Why'd you bring that up?
Welfare on the office
because I,
that's pretty crazy that,
uh,
um,
that's big.
That's huge.
It was.
It Will Ferrell.
I don't watch those sitcoms.
I fucking love welfare.
Oh Man.
I've never watched sitcoms.
Let me get around the office.
I get around to a south park every now and then if I'm going to watch something
that's funny,
but I don't
spend too much time watching Oprah.
I need it.
No,
don't do that.
It helps me Brown.
It helps me.
It helps me understand those people.
I was wireless and I'd come from conservative talk radio to,
I mean I listen to conservative talk radio because I don't know anybody like
that.
I want to know how this fucking people think and when I have those,
you know what the libs don't know.
Okay.
I'll tell you right now.
Here's what the libs don't know.
Oh,
Barma doesn't like you either.
Okay.
Obama is one of those elite estimate and I like listening to that shit because
this,
this fucking guy believes this.
He selling this.
I was listening to Glenn Black back this morning.
I stopped in my driveway for five minutes just sitting there shaking my head,
listening to Glenn Beck this morning just like this is crazy ass hole and thinks
that the reason why the fucking tsunami and earthquake happened is because we're
not following the 10 commandments.
That crazy.
Ansul Ashley suggested that,
you know,
so I,
I look,
I listened to everybody.
So Oprah's on the list too,
man.
I gotta I gotta listen,
I gotta find out what she's up to.
Hmm.
Fucking yeah,
you got to fight.
No,
I,
I just don't even,
that's like,
it seems like a bunch of serious stuff to watch,
I guess.
I don't know.
I mean,
I like,
if I'm going to watch anything serious,
it's going to be like fucking cops are murder stuff so I can,
you know,
at least learn a skill trade if I'm going to murder somebody,
how I can get away with it.
Interventions.
Do you ever feeling down about yourself intervention?
Never want to like know that you're going to be okay.
Watch intervention,
every rehab,
no intervention,
all of those things where people are falling apart and then people have to go
and rescue them.
People that are doing crack and heroin and love that crazy now.
So that's part of celebrity rehab.
That's my favorite show.
My favorite part of celebrity rehab is a fucking,
um,
what's his name?
Eric Roberts.
Yeah.
That guy was on.
It just needs a friend Rehab for weed.
Yeah,
it was hilarious.
He never had a problem.
People were falling apart all around them.
He's in the back reading it like on the side reading a newspaper.
What does glas is eating a sandwich?
He never had a story.
I mean he did have like a rough childhood.
I mean the problem with that shows he cried once.
He cried once,
but like a doctor Jude talks so much shit on weed that when he,
when Eric Roberts came to him,
he's a celebrity.
He needs a celebrity man.
Not very many celebrities will go on that show.
They go,
we got Eric Roberts cause what's to here for,
for weed?
What are you going to tell him?
I mean he tells every doctor who tells everybody that weed's bad for you.
So he's gotta admit him when really he has no problem.
That was the craziest part.
He has his problems.
He does nothing to do with the weeding.
Yeah.
It didn't eat well.
He was using weed as an escape from his life and it just happened to be weed.
It could have been cough syrup.
No.
He could have found some other shit.
This case.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I guess.
But I think it was just,
I think it was a way to blow up Eric Roberts and he doesn't look bad.
I don't know what an easy way to,
to rejuvenate the career.
Celebrity Rehab is fucking cute.
You know what,
he didn't,
he,
well,
he didn't look bad at all.
The very,
the very first day when the analyze them,
he said,
doc,
I,
I smoke from a vaporizer.
They show me it's healthier.
He's talking about a big prize.
I was healthier and he didn't smoke that much at all.
And he said,
when I smoke,
everybody loves me.
I am in a great mood,
you know,
um,
I flow.
But when I don't smoke,
I get,
you know,
in a cranky mood and I,
and I'm pissed off.
That's what he said the problem is.
And doctors with us,
hmm,
we've got to work on that.
He showed him that he's smoking out of the vaporizer.
So I think that Eric Roberts and go,
this is a perfect way.
Well for
doctor drew,
man,
there's no solution other than sobriety.
You know,
I've,
I,
I retweeted something.
I'd say,
I think,
I forget what someone tweeted something about pot and I retweeted it going suck
on that doctor drew,
you know,
like to him thinking that I've been friends with that guy for years.
When are we going to get him on?
We've gotten lot of love to,
yes,
he got mad at me.
Whoa.
I've been friends with him for years and he's like,
Hey Joe,
I'm sorry I'm killing your,
hi.
What the hell man?
Whoa.
Yeah,
Whoa are attacking me or something like that.
And I go,
well dude,
I'm just as just a joke.
I thought you knew my son's a who are,
you know,
I love you.
And he writes back,
I love you too.
So it was cool.
I mean,
it all wind up Cuba.
He thought that I was like really like fuck you doctor drew socket back.
Some guys you can't joke around like that.
You can't,
like,
you could text me something and say suck on that bitch.
And I would be like,
yeah,
I would laugh.
Have,
you could do it too,
but with Dr Drew,
apparently you can't text Dr drew and say suck on it bitch.
She texted him or emailed him.
Twitter does.
Do you think you'll ever digital shit onto the I twittered it so that everyone
saw.
Yeah,
but come on man.
It's funny.
Hey,
so,
um,
the fuck do you think you would ever do,
did that did the show?
No,
but I'm going to do Loveline I'm going to do,
maybe he was kidding about doing it.
Maybe he was kidding.
Mike is on dancing with the stars right now.
What exactly did he say again?
Maybe he don't know.
He wasn't kidding.
You got it.
You got a little upset.
He thought it was actually upset when I was staying stuck on that.
He was like,
I'm sorry I'm killing your high with the helmet man.
Get it.
Seemed like he was hurting.
His feelings were hurt.
Like I attacked him.
Okay.
This is the only discussion that we,
he and I have ever disagreed on.
I,
I think that he's absolutely right about how much abuse goes on and you know,
like when,
when he can nail it,
when he's talking to people about like what's wrong with them?
What I think is he discounts that there are very healthy people that can benefit
from marijuana and that's,
that's the difference.
I'm,
you know,
people that aren't sick that don't have addiction problems,
that don't have substance problems,
they can benefit greatly from marijuana.
And the problem is he's dealing with a completely tainted pool.
Everyone that he's dealing with,
it's fucked up.
He's his very few people that he's dealing with that aren't,
he's an addiction specialist.
He's,
he's,
by the time they get to him,
they're life is in the God damn toilet.
They're fucking falling apart.
He's not necessarily sitting down with people that can say,
hey doctor drew,
listen man,
marijuana has made me a better person.
I'm a,
I'm a different
person because of it.
Okay,
so,
so what do you think it is?
He'll be,
you could be as a person anyway.
It's either one of two things.
Either.
He actually doesn't know.
That doesn't meet as good for you or he knows,
but because he's a doctor,
he doesn't want to hurt his reputation.
No.
Look,
he'll tell you it's better for you than alcohol for sure.
I mean,
yeah,
but does he know the truth?
Medical,
he's very honest.
He has another,
doesn't know.
He believes that it's bad for you and he,
you know,
he believes that a,
it's a addictive,
whether it's physically a diff addictive or psychologically,
it's really no.
You know,
when people say there's no,
marijuana is not addictive.
Everything you fucking do can be addictive.
If your mind is broken,
if your mind gets wacky,
you know,
I've seen people,
you're,
you know,
anybody that's a gambling addict.
Given that people like that,
I know a few people personally.
Yeah,
see it's a nutty thing,
right?
They can help them and they,
they,
whatever it is,
you can call it a psychological addiction.
Whatever it is.
They are connected.
The gambling,
they can't stop gambling.
They do it all the time.
I know a bunch of people from the pool world,
from my days of playing pool there.
I've met so many people that were gambling addicts.
That's,
that's an addict addiction to man.
Marijuana can be addictive.
Absolutely.
Anything can be addictive if your mind is broken.
But that doesn't mean that people like us whose brains aren't broken shouldn't
be allowed to use it.
That's,
that's where it gets annoying.
And when NFA to benefit you and when you tell him that it does,
there should be some sort of a test and we tell them that it does.
That's the only thing that ever annoys me about doctor Joe said he's not willing
to sort of take that into consideration.
He,
he's a pretty rigid on his stance when it comes to to psychedelic drugs and to
test that.
That's the only part that I can't stand as he,
he's,
does it know the truth about marijuana?
I thought maybe he does know,
but he's just trying to save his job and he can't talk about it because
technically it's still illegal so I can't promote it.
I thought it was that and like he did know the truth,
but either way,
that would still be something that I wasn't,
I wouldn't be happy with.
I'm like,
did do the research,
get on,
get on the Internet,
Dr Julia a doctor,
come on,
look into it.
It's going to,
you'll actually benefit from it.
You Yourself,
yes,
you will benefit from it.
Most certainly adopted.
Just started smoking weed every now and then your life would change in a better
way.
Doctor drew and you don't even know it.
And you're a doctor and you're on TV.
Man,
I love you.
I've been listening to you from love line,
from back when I in 1989 back in the day.
I love doctor [inaudible].
I love 90% of what you say,
but the 10% about the,
the um,
uh,
you not knowing the truth about marijuana that,
that burns me in inside Bhutan.
Mccormick school them on Loveline years ago when he was talking about it,
you know,
he's,
he's definitely not,
uh,
not objective when it comes to that,
but I,
you know,
whatever,
that's him.
That's what you know,
it's the path he's on.
It's unfortunate.
I think you would,
I think all people can learn from psychedelic experiences if you're,
if you're not fucked up,
there's,
if there's not something wrong with you medically,
there's not something wrong and you psychologically where you really can't go on
trips.
You know,
even just trips of eating weed,
that shit you benefits you greatly in Brazil where Iowasca is legal.
The people that are part of the IOWASCA churches and they're just normal loving
people.
They give Iowasca to their kids
when they turn 14 to make sure that will become alcoholics cause I lost at that
age.
Right when the hitting puberty,
it's sets them,
it sets the brain straight somehow.
And I Wasco,
if you know what it is,
it's a,
it's the key to the other side,
to the spirit world.
It really is.
And when you see the spirit world at 14 somehow it,
it keeps them from,
from being alcoholics.
They do that in Brazil.
Straightens you out man.
When you,
when you've had experiences like the,
the DMT experience,
which if people don't know Iowasca is the DMT experience.
Iowasca is an orally active version of DMT and the reason it's orally active as
opposed to the regular version is that DMT,
when you eat it is broken down your stomach by something called the monoamine
oxidase and Mano Aiming Oxidase,
um,
is a,
is produced by your stomach and it kills it so you,
when you eat it,
nothing happens.
So what these people figured out how to do,
and this is app,
there's hundreds of thousands of different plants in the Amazon figured out how
to take the route of one tree and the leaves of another and they combine them
and one of them has DMT and the other one has an unnatural m,
a o Mano,
Amy and oxidase inhibitor.
So it inhibits your stomachs production of monoamine oxidase.
And it allows a DMT to get into your bloodstream orally or,
and it takes a long time.
It takes like five or six hours for the full trip and it's,
it's like a ride through to the other side.
It's like,
it allows you during that brief amount of time to tune in to the spirit world,
which is all around us all the time.
And you know,
it's a,
it's a huge part of their culture and it's been something that has,
you know,
been passed on from generation to generation and it's a really incredible
discovery because they figured out an all those plants,
they figure out how to take this,
a little bit of this,
a little bit of that,
mix it together,
boil it's strain it out,
drink it,
throw up.
It tastes like dog shit tastes terrible.
It's a long ass process to make this.
But they figured out how to do this.
It's a really amazing discovery because they didn't figure out anything else.
They have dirt floors and shit.
They don't even have shoes yet.
They're out there.
Make an IOWASCA connecting to the spirit world on a regular basis.
And you know,
when you,
you say,
well we're advanced,
you know those,
those are those poor people.
They're not advanced.
Well,
they're way more advanced.
Yeah.
They don't have supermarkets,
but guess what?
They live in a place where food is everywhere.
Okay.
And they go to the spirit world all the time,
like they're completely connected to the afterlife.
If anybody realizes that this is all just a bullshit good time and just try to
enjoy it as much as you can.
They do.
Those fucking people are knocking on the door every day.
They're there going back and forth all the time.
They're not lost in the jungle.
They're completely aware of Western civilization and technology.
They know all about it.
Once you go to the other side,
apparently you realize all that matters is,
is being harmonious with Mother Nature.
And once you see the spirit world and you see it so clearly,
like all the materialistic stuff in the world apparently seems to not be so
anymore.
Your priorities change up and you know it.
I didn't do Iowasca I did the real,
I,
I sloped DMT with,
um,
that's the 10 minute version of an eight hour trip.
What's actually much of,
it's very,
very difficult to get the full DMT experience when you're drinking.
Iowasca it's a long experience,
but it's not a slow,
Mckenna always described it as like,
uh,
you know,
like you,
you compress a file and then you download it and then you uncompress it on your
hard drive and it becomes fucking huge.
You know?
He's like,
that's what DMTs like,
it's like you're,
you're downloading something that it's just going to explode in your brain and
you know,
and,
and Un unhinge and,
uh,
you know,
give you the full effect in 10,
15 minutes as opposed to the IOWASCA trip changed my life and I don't want to
get into change.
Mine too.
And we've talked about it a bunch of times.
I have done it a bunch of times.
To me it confirming,
I grew up very religious and then at 10 when I found out that everybody wasn't
Catholic,
I thought everybody was Catholic.
Everybody in my neighborhood was Catholic.
We had a couple of Protestants in the school.
I didn't know what that was.
I was a little confused.
And then we had a couple of Jehovah's witness and I was like,
hmm.
But mostly everybody was Catholic.
All of the sitcoms that the kids watched back then coincided with Catholic
holiday.
So we see Christmas specials and we see Easter.
So I just thought everybody was Catholic.
You know,
I was an altar boy.
I'm like,
I can't wait to get to heaven cause lat life sucks.
Once I found out that there was Jews out there and I found out,
I'm like,
what's a Jew is?
Is that a person?
Oh No,
it's a religion and there's other religions.
Then I became a atheist once I found out there was a thousand religions and I
went,
oh,
it's this muscly,
all be bullshit,
you know?
So then I became super atheistic,
started writing songs about Satan.
I didn't believe in Satan,
but I'm like,
I don't believe in anything and I'm going to scare all these Christians and I'm
a write about Satan killing priests and stuff.
Didn't I was an atheist.
I mean I was,
I didn't believe in God at all.
And then when I was at 21,
I had an experience that made me realize that there might be some stuff out
there.
Um,
should I tell the psychic story?
Oh,
tell whatever you want,
man.
Um,
well that's an interesting story when from atheism to egg,
uh,
being an agnostic at 21 was wa I'm just moved to Hollywood to be a rock star and
walking up sunset boulevard passing the Roxy and my buddy John was like 10,
15 yards ahead of me.
And in front of the Roxy there's this hippie plan.
Um,
he's playing guitar and he's,
and he has this sign about the Amazon rain forest getting chopped down and all
this stuff and he's just a dirty hippy to me.
And I pass by and he's all tree hugging.
And I looked at him and in my mind I'm like,
you know,
take a shower.
But I didn't actually say that.
And as if he read my mind,
he stopped playing,
walked up to me,
looked me in the face and said,
if I guessed your birthday,
will you listen to me?
And I'm like,
yeah,
right.
And he looked at me in the eye and said,
fine.
He said,
May,
May 15th I'm like,
Holy Shit.
I said,
John,
come here.
I,
I waved my friend over and I as if that wasn't enough.
He had to do it again for the confirmation.
I said,
guess his birthday and John
didn't know what that was going on.
He said he looked at John and said,
March 30 31st Mike,
Mike,
Mike is the probabilities.
Yeah,
let's look at probability,
probability,
theater,
theory.
Remember that conversation?
We had a conversation with a friend of ours at that point he was telling his
story and the guy goes,
might it's probabilities,
probability theory.
If you follow probability theory,
there's a way to do that so you can figure out someone's birthday.
I mean,
what the fuck are you talking about man?
You can't just guess one day and then another guy comes over.
He gets that day too though.
That's insane.
That's our probability theory.
Probability theory says it's very unlikely that you would be able to do that.
Yeah,
so he started talking about the rain forest.
We just stood there with our jaws dropped.
I didn't listen to anything he said all I kept thinking about it,
how the hell did he do that?
I was amazing.
So I came to a conclusion,
it's gotta be one of two things.
Either he could somehow read thoughts and if you think something,
there's people that could see the thoughts somehow.
It's like a weird other sense or there was some voice,
whether it's an angel or a demon or a spirit or whatever,
or the akashic records.
It's something telling him.
And then he had had,
so to me I became agnostic,
which meant I'm like okay maybe I don't know what the fuck is going on.
And how old were you when this happened?
I was 21 so what do you think happened?
He seen that dude was doing Iowasca and he just tripped all the time and had
some sort of a,
a constant connection to the spirit world who's running around being selfless.
Only trying to help people and looking like a bum.
Yup.
Cause if he's,
if he's dedicating his life to saving the rainforest,
he's got like,
she's super over active when it comes to like loving the planet.
Like he loves the planet so much that he's dedicated his whole life.
He's not taking showers.
He's on the sunset playing guitar.
He's dedicated his whole life.
That guy,
that guy.
Nobody loves the planet more than that dude.
You know,
I was listening to a Mckenna,
uh,
podcast,
I forget psychedelic cafe,
I think is the name of the podcast.
And I had a Terence Mckenna speech where he was talking about it.
Everybody's so concerned about the rain forest and everyone's so concerned about
the environment and pollution and toxifications of the ocean.
But if just one,
just one of these things and has hit the earth so many times in the past came
here from outer space,
you wouldn't have to worry about anything anymore.
There'd be nothing left.
You know,
he's talking about though the,
the media that hit the Yucatan and how that within the first,
second and a half,
it was five miles deep into the earth for
the first,
second and a half.
It was five miles deep.
And that's dead.
Fuck the ozone layer.
Fuck the rain forest.
Fuck everything.
It's all done.
And those,
Goddamn,
every planet is littered with these giant craters.
They're all over Jupiter.
There all we've seen them hit in our lifetime and he knows an amateur astronomer
very recently in Australia.
That caught a big impact in Jupiter.
We've seen it in,
you know,
we,
we seen them hip Jupiter before.
Um,
there was one big one I believe in [inaudible] 94,
you know,
shoemaker Levy.
I think it was a big comment that slammed in.
I mean,
look,
it's some scary ass fucking shit and there's so many of 'em out there.
There's so many of them that didn't,
that incident didn't make me become a tree hugger,
but it did make me,
um,
uh,
did put me on a quest to find out.
Like,
I just instantly became fascinated at how we can get that.
What do you think?
I mean,
you had to be,
you had a think about that gun?
I said it was either to me it was either he could read thought either.
Whatever.
Did you ask her?
No,
I didn't ask him.
Whoa.
Either.
He,
why didn't you ask him?
I don't.
Maybe I did.
And he said,
don't worry about it.
You know,
I just know it can hold them back on the ability to run.
I just know something.
So to me,
this shit,
to me,
he did it.
It didn't matter how he did it.
I wouldn't even let him talk anymore.
I'd be like,
come on bitch.
Yeah,
spread that shit around.
I want to know numbers.
Um,
I just knew that that had to be something that we don't understand,
that it has to be like another dimension or something.
So I became obsessed with finding out what life really is.
You know,
I've just always been on that quest.
That's how I became a conspiracy theorists.
That's why,
you know,
um,
uh,
fascinated with ancient cultures and what they did.
I'm old,
I have stacks and stacks of DVDs just like you,
stacks of DVDs of conspiracy theories and uh,
you know,
documentaries on ancient cultures and you know,
the government and how the government works at all this stuff that set me on the
course right there to find out,
uh,
what's really going on.
Is there an afterlife?
I mean that's important.
It became important to me to find out if there is,
if the,
is there some kind of higher power,
you know,
so that set it up.
So I became agnostic and through DMT and all the things that I've been through,
um,
to me I feel I'm pretty certain there's an afterlife that we don't just die and
just were just done.
I believe that there is,
there is the Akashic records and the ancient Indians believed I'm from India.
They believe,
you know,
they call,
they dubbed it.
The akashic records is there's in the afterworld there's a river of infinite
information that you can have access to the answers to everything and you know,
through meditation and just sort of controlling your own frequency.
You know,
people have done it.
It's,
it's,
it's been done.
There's been,
the most famous in the West was Edgar Casey.
He had the knowledge to tap into this information and no one can figure it out.
He has like 13 or 14,000 documented readings.
He got huge.
The president came to him,
he was,
you know,
he was a guy with a third grade education,
but when he went under and is medium state,
he had the answers to everything.
He was like this,
like this,
this man in a,
in a different voice and would just have the answers to everything.
It was,
if anybody debunked
Edgar Casey.
Oh right.
Read any of that shit.
You can't debunk him.
He smashes you.
Just look into him.
He smashes,
she knew in 1920 he knew like the function of every gland and no one knew if he
was bullshitting cause they didn't even know back then.
We're finding the shit.
He's saying we're finding out the shit now.
But he was right.
He did.
He would rattle off like the pituitary gland and give you like what vitamins you
need to take,
what's its function going through all the glands and people with,
oh,
he's crazy.
But he had a documented mds are going back and studying in his,
his readings and going,
Holy Shit,
there's,
you can't debunk him.
He had the power,
he had the power to reach and he's not the only one.
There's a lot of people that can do,
do you know meditation helps,
you know,
you yourself have even said through a meditating in your tank that you feel like
you have access to information.
Well,
I definitely feel like the,
the closer you get to being at peace and in the right frequency and then you can
direct your frequency.
I really do believe that.
I believe that with the tank and with,
especially if I go onto the tank under the influence of the sacred plant and I
and I and I,
and I get into the groove of,
of completely,
totally letting go and and trying to abandon all that is about me and just try
to be empty and just tune into it.
There's a,
there's a place that I get to,
it's almost like our goal on this little journey and I've got to keep it
together while I'm going on this journey because sometimes when I'm on it,
it could get a little weird.
I start thinking about myself or about my life or about anything else,
and then I,
it interrupts my progress,
but if I can tune in and stay in long enough,
it's like I go through a tunnel and then when I get through the tunnel,
if I can keep it together,
I get through the tunnel and then I break on through to the other side.
And when I break on through to the other side,
it literally is like I get to another place.
And so I got to go through this tunnel,
this tunnel of,
of,
it's almost like tuning my mind into the perfect frequency and whether or not
I'm willing to let go of all of my control,
all my control,
my thinking,
and if I can,
if I can,
it's,
it's literally like a magical event,
man.
Why I popped through this tunnel on the other side and there's this beautiful,
incredible psychedelic world over there,
psychedelic world of patterns and,
and,
and communication.
And it's a,
it's like a mushroom trip.
It's like a DMT trip.
Yes.
So either a that's imaginary and it's all just in your head.
It's a trip or B,
it's actually some place.
Well you know the real,
and I don't think there is anything that's imaginary.
This is my thinking about the imagination.
This is what I think man.
Your imagination,
you're a very creative person.
I think of all the different things that you've thought of,
you know,
whether you were when we were writing shit for the man show or whether you're
creating Jujitsu moves,
whatever it is you think it,
and then it manifests itself in a,
in a real form,
as a real thing,
a solid object.
It was at one point in time,
just a thought,
like the ability to put something in a can.
Somebody had to think this up,
how to make a fucking can and then figure out how many coconuts you'd have to
squash to,
to get all this coconut juice into this camp.
There's a lot of work involved in that,
but you,
someone has to create it and think it.
And so the imagination allows you to think of these ideas and then they manifest
themselves in a real form.
So the real question is what the fuck is the imagination?
What,
what is,
what is when you're thinking things up and someone comes up with the idea of
nuclear power,
I mean granted there's a bunch of steps along the way.
A bunch of other discoveries have to be made.
A bunch of things have to be pieced together to get to a point where you're,
you know,
making a nuclear power plant or an airplane or fucking anything really
complicated.
But the bottom line is all of it has come out of nothing.
All of it,
every idea ever has come out of the air.
It's the imagination.
So,
so what is it?
So you're saying be it's someplace.
So,
and if you look at the ancient Indians and it,
you know,
is there an Akashic records?
Is there proof?
Yes,
there's a lots of proof.
But the undeniable proof,
you look at Edgar Casey,
he proves that you can somehow under hypnosis or in a trance or in meditation,
you can tap into this infinite knowledge,
these answers that came from somewhere else.
So if there is this infinite river of knowledge or,
um,
what the hell is it?
Who created it?
What's it for?
Is there,
is there consciousness behind it?
Get something created?
Is there,
do we,
when we exist in the spirit world,
our,
we'd like this super infinite.
I mean cause if you listened to the,
the,
the mystics and ancient cultures,
the mediums,
if you look at all the things they all agree on,
they all say,
and even tenants,
the Kenya has said this,
that in the afterlife and the other dimension,
there is no time.
There's no path,
there's no presence.
There's just now everything happens at the same time.
No human can actually understand that or understand what that feels.
They can't wrap their brain around it.
I can't,
I can say it,
but I don't really know what it feels like.
But that's what they all say.
There is no time.
And this dimension that we're living in is an illusion of time.
We see that as time moves into linear,
a linear fashion.
So we perceive it as time and like what does that really mean?
This is an illusion really.
Like what could it mean?
And if there is this river of infinite knowledge,
God dammit,
whatever created that for sure is there's some intelligent design going on like
that's what I'm coming.
That's the conclusion I'm coming to.
That's not just some natural phenomena where there's infinite knowledge of
certain people in our meditation can tap into it.
That sounds like there's some awesome shit that created that for multiple
dimensions.
Right?
Right.
If it exists and then you backtrack,
they it exist.
Yes.
There's lots of proof that it is there.
People are taking information.
The guy who gets my birthday on my friend's birthday,
he tapped into this infinite river of knowledge.
The ancient cultures all talk about
vanguard,
man.
Of course there's good,
but you can call it not like the bearded man.
No law created like there is a higher power.
There is intelligent design.
There is.
This is if is what
we know.
Is it that it's embarrassing for this universe if we're the smart,
nobody know shit.
Yeah,
but that's,
but that's not embarrassing because at one point in time it had to be lower than
us.
If the big bang actually created the universe.
At one point in time,
like a day old was the universe like,
God,
you should be embarrassed with yourself.
This is it.
You don't even have worms yet.
You fucking loser.
Well,
the whole universe,
if,
if everything evolves it at one point in time it has to be in a low form.
You know,
and what we are in this,
you know,
if this is a universe,
if this is a dimension,
you know what,
what,
whatever you want to classify this space that we dwell in,
you know,
whether when do you think it's one part of the great beyond,
it's all attached together.
Whatever the fuck it is.
This part is at this stage,
this is where it is,
you know,
as embarrassing as what we are right now,
this may very well be as far as it gets.
Maybe.
I mean,
if we think that there are aliens and we think that aliens at one point in time
used to be a,
you know,
a like us and then they evolved and became much better than us.
Well that means they had to be,
like I said,
at one point,
for sure somebody,
somebody that the,
the,
the fucking top of the line,
the front of the line had to be like us at one point in time.
There's no argument revolution.
Maybe it's obsolete.
It might be us.
Even an evolution and a higher power and intelligent design at the same time.
How could trippy would that be though is we really were the top of the line as
far as intelligence goes,
as far as the universe.
What if we really are the only one that would be a trip man.
Ridiculous.
Hey,
wouldn't be incredible.
It would mean,
it sounds,
it sounds ridiculous.
Cogs that we,
oh,
we're number one.
We're lucky.
But here's the thing.
It had to happen somewhere once,
right?
If it's,
if it happens here,
right?
If we,
if we are the ones and we've gotten to this point then just because I'm not
saying this right,
but because it's happening here,
it doesn't mean that it's happening somewhere else.
It might literally only be happening here.
I believe that I believe in evolution.
Absolutely.
I mean there's so much proof of it,
but there's also like these inconsistencies with it too and like the missing
Lincoln and they don't come out of that is just a lack of understanding on a,
on a,
on a slope.
I believe that there is,
if there's an,
if there's an akashic records,
if there's an infinite river of knowledge,
there's an a,
there's definitely,
in my eyes,
the,
the conclusion would be that that there is a higher power with higher
intelligence than what were were someone else.
We're not creating that shit.
Somebody created that.
We can't fucking make an infinite river knowledge that we can just grab it like
a supercomputer.
We're still on that tops.
I'm saying that that proves that there's something way beyond us.
Wavy on might not be that simple.
It might be something like we're moving towards becoming that.
It might be that.
It might be that there is no god and there is no,
there's no one who's at the wheel of this whole thing,
but that the whole thing is moving in a direction.
The way to move in the correct direction is to move towards God.
Who's to move towards,
loves to move towards friendship and happiness.
And that's why when you crack through to the next stage,
when you're,
when you have that DMT trip and you go over there,
it's like what you're trying to do is to get there,
but you're trying to do is to tune in to how they're tuned in.
You know?
And then it's not even that there's a thing behind it.
Since you are it,
you are that thing.
We all are that water molecules in the ocean.
That's,
that's one of the conclusions and theories based on all the shit that I've
heard.
It seems like the afterworld is like an ocean.
It is like God is one God as ocean,
but we're all part of it.
We're all like a water molecule.
We're all affected.
It's the ultimate mind fuck.
It's the ultimate mind fuck to think affect you.
You know,
and you're,
your own biology is sort of betraying you and to thinking that you're an
individual and that you're not a part of some gigantic fucking thing that's all
happening.
But one of the things that you've realized and I've realized over the course of
our friendship,
I mean Eddie has been my best friend since I think 2000 we started hanging out
in 2010 which is,
and that's back to the,
it comes back to the story of the twister.
Oh.
Because this is how we became good friends.
Um,
I was uh,
getting uh,
uh,
private lessons when I first started doing Jujitsu.
I was a blue belt under this dude.
I won't say his name is a very nice guy,
but it's an,
I'm going to say something negative and I was,
because I was getting a private lessons from him all the time.
He was the only guy that I was rolling with and I wasn't really learning nearly
as much as I thought.
I thought like if you're a kickboxing and like you say,
if you get a chance to work out with rob came in,
it's way better to work out with rob came in one on one than it is to go to a
private class.
Like he's going to correct all your techniques.
So I thought that would be the case with Jujitsu.
Like I would get really good going to class and ain't like that.
Eddie was the first person to tell me.
And uh,
Eddie came to a,
a,
one of the private lessons that I was having when Silvio and we rolled around a
little bit and white away.
He got me in a twister and I had no idea what the fuck he's doing.
All of a sudden he hooks my knee with his left leg and his left foot goes under
his right knee and he rolls forward under his left shoulder and I'm spinning
around like a top.
And next thing I know he's got my arm wrapped around his neck and he's fucking
pulling on my neck like this.
I was like,
what the fuck did you just do?
Like I had been doing Jujitsu for two years and I had no idea what the fuck you
just did to me.
And I was like,
God damn.
And you're like,
I'll teach you all this shit.
I was like,
dude,
teach me this shit.
And that's how we became friends.
And that's also how I started smoking pot.
You know,
I was on the Mark Marin podcast the other day and this came up.
Um,
you know,
I,
I've thought that marijuana and all that stuff was for losers.
I thought that it just made you a loser.
You're just going to become unmotivated.
You're not going to get anything done.
You're going to be a dummy and just sit and watch TV.
That's not what I wanted,
man.
I wanted to make sure we're like our friend bud.
We have a good friend,
but who's like super fucking go getter.
You know,
bud is a great guy.
He,
he's the one who put together the TV show to build that car,
that Barracuda.
And he's also the one who did my garage,
like an MMA garage.
She's always got like a bunch of different TV shows going on and he's a fucking
go getter and you and I are always like,
dude,
please just let us get you high.
How many times more than Dr Drew?
More than anybody.
How many times we've been having this conversation with him and he's always
like,
after I make my first million and then he makes his first million,
or like I'm still looking,
I'm like,
I don't want to slow down now.
Like he just does not want to slow it down and we're like,
it ain't about slowing down man.
It's not about,
I'm not slowing down.
I haven't slowed down at all.
I work more now than I ever did before.
I'm a busy amount of fun.
That's it.
Isn't that a annoying goddamn stereotype that potheads or are lazy?
We
get a lot of shit done,
dude.
I'm doing two podcasts a week.
I'm writing a book,
I'm writing my standup comedy and performing stand up comedy and I'm doing
standup.
I'm,
I'm doing a,
the,
the commentary for the number one mixed martial arts organization in the fucking
world and I'm training Jujitsu and I'm doing kettlebells and I'm raising kids
and I play pool every night and I got to surf the Internet and I got to beat
off.
There's a lot of shit going on,
man.
There's a lot of God damn time.
I'm not lazy at all.
I squeeze it all into every day.
So when people say that potheads you know that it makes you lazy.
It's just a stereotype man.
And that was the stereotype that I thought before I met you,
man.
I do sleep till about 10 45 every day.
So what time do you go to bed?
We tell him to go to bed.
Two or three.
Yeah,
that's like eight hours.
That's what you're supposed to get,
man.
Most of these people were in bed at 10 o'clock at night.
That's why when they get up at six o'clock in the morning,
they're all impressed with themselves.
My,
yeah,
bitch,
I slept till one 30 in the afternoon,
but where were you at 5:00 AM?
I was writing the greatest bit I've ever written in my life.
Okay.
That's why I write my best shit.
I was in the fucking isolation tank traveling through the universe.
All right.
That's what I was doing while you were sleeping.
So they'll give me a hard time because my time is different than your time.
Like somehow or another,
you know,
you,
you were fucking doing yoga at 5:00 AM so you're the king.
Fuck you stupid.
And it's all based on farmers anyway,
based on it's based on farms.
You have to fucking get up early.
That's nonsense asleep.
The crazy thing is that Joe and I,
before we started smoking weed,
we were totally against it.
We weren't bag on stoners and we thought it made you stupid.
I would talk so much shit on stone or is that at 28 that's when I found out the
truth.
That's when I reaped the benefits of marijuana.
And then when I met Joe,
he was so funny.
I thought this guy's got a smoke pot.
He's so funny.
Like I go see him,
you know,
do stand up at the comedy store and I'm like,
that's that dude who transit Jonjak Machado's he tries to at my school,
Hey,
what's up dude,
I train at your school.
And I was like,
watch them do comedy.
And I thought it was Greg and he's got a smoking.
Eddie and I had a bunch of fortuitous meetings just out of the,
out of the blue before we became friends at one time,
Eddie,
his eyes aren't so good.
And one time we were at a,
uh,
at Mel's diner and it was late at night,
man,
it was like one o'clock in the morning.
And I'm like,
Yo,
ed,
hey,
Yo Eddie.
And he's like,
man,
who's this motherfucker talking to me,
I'm going to have to fight this dude in front of my chick.
Well that's,
you remember that?
Oh my God,
Yeah,
you taught,
I was like some dude who's just fucking with you.
So I had it down.
I'm like,
I thought you were.
Cause I was with the check and I,
you were saying something to the check.
I got,
you didn't hear what I was saying and you can't see that good.
So you couldn't see me from a distance.
So by the time I came up to your table,
like who's his mother fucker?
And then you'll,
oh hey dude,
I didn't watch newsradio and at that point it was before a fear factor.
So I never watched news radio.
And so I was like,
okay,
I hear he's an actor or something,
like I barely remembered you.
But then when I saw you at the college,
that was by luck to,
you didn't come there with me.
You just came.
Yeah.
I was just super human.
Fran,
I want to go see come cause right when I started smoking weed,
I began to appreciate comedy way more because uh,
we better all of a sudden my,
my mind figured out how to write comedy.
Right.
When I started smoking weed,
I never understood.
I was fascinated with Connie,
but
I never understood how to put bits together.
I didn't understand the setup.
I didn't understand the structure of comedy.
But as soon as I start smoking weed,
I'm like,
I know where they're doing.
I know what they're doing now they're doing this and they're taking that and
then do it.
So I understood the basic for me.
So I just became fascinated and then I saw you.
I'm like,
does that do for my Jujitsu school?
He's an actor and you killed me.
You were just,
you were all nothing but dick jokes and like relationship jokes,
chick jokes,
dating Joe.
But you would kill in it.
And then when you came you walked off stage.
I'm like,
hey dude,
what's up dude?
I know you fucking were awesome.
And then we,
then that's when he invited me to give him a private or something like that was
after you at when those taking privates with that dude.
Yeah.
And then you came down to class and then,
and then the,
the pot smoking began.
That was it.
Yeah.
You know,
it took me it,
I thought you totally smoked weed.
So it's us.
I tell about the story.
It's kind of illegal.
Oh,
one thing.
The one part about the story,
sodomy is not,
oh
yeah,
but it's legal now.
Weed's legal now.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Totally.
You're alive.
That's cryptic shit for you bitches.
Listen,
this Goddamn podcasts been going on long enough.
If it wasn't for Eddie Bravo,
I would have never got into Jujitsu.
It wasn't for any bravo.
I'll never would have become a stoner.
So one of my fucking favorite human beings to walk the face of the earth.
He could find him on Twitter,
e d d I e B r a v O on Twitter.
And your website is 10th planet j J.
Dot Com.
Right?
Yup.
I'm on the forum every day.
The new bureau forum and Brian Red Band.
You can catch him on Twitter at Red Band Red Ban,
and please follow him.
He's getting very insecure.
He's got such a high desk squad iTunes rating.
It's like number 13 and shed.
It's blowing the fuck up,
but yet his goddamn Twitter.
So minuscule.
Well I've just surpassed the 300,000 mark bitches.
Can I say one more thing?
For sure.
Yeah.
Um,
we were talking about Michael Jai white earlier.
I just want to say that that never back down to Michael [inaudible] was a
producer of star director.
He wanted to make sure that it was NMA authentic,
so and not be anything like the first one.
So never back down to,
you know,
he brought me in as a consultant.
I ended up getting a little part,
I got a couple songs on the soundtrack,
but we did our best to make it,
uh,
to fill all the holes to make sure that a hardcore MMA fan could come and watch
this movie and couldn't poke any holes.
And there's a twister in there too.
I choreographed a fight when he gets a guided twister when and it seemed,
it seemed at that point like,
you know,
like there was no twisters in the UFC,
so I could see like the producers as I'm putting it together,
like,
are you sure we're going to do this?
I mean,
this is legit or are people going to,
isn't this like a double flip kick and thank God the Korean Zombie pulled out to
business.
So now it,
it legitimizes that part of the movie as well.
So there's rubber guard in the movies,
which we did our best with it.
Matt,
I saw a rough cut of it.
I loved it.
So cool.
All right.
This weekend,
uh,
Portland there with Joey Diaz,
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday at the helium comedy club.
That shit is all almost sold out.
If you want tickets,
you've got to jump on it right now because a,
there was very few left of today.
So,
uh,
get in there.
Thank you everybody for Seattle.
The Moore Theater was fucking sold out and it was crazy.
And the Voodoo chicken went on stage for the very first time.
It was absolutely spectacular.
Seattle,
you guys are the shit.
I had a great fucking time.
And when I said,
how many people listen to the podcast?
Like 99% of the crowd went crazy.
It's all podcasts,
people.
Now these crowds are all podcast,
podcast crowds.
It's nuts.
Thank you very much.
With the flashlight to the flashlight,
if you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link that says fleshlight and enter
in a code name,
Rogan,
you get 15% off.
So that's it.
Freaks.
Wednesday we're doing Joey Diaz.
Joey Diaz will be on the podcast Wednesday and then Wednesday night we'll be at
Sal's comedy hole in La Patches.
You know,
I love you.
Saturday night or Saturday,
the Saturday 10 planet Springfield.
I'll be there teaching assembly field,
Massachusetts.
No,
no,
a Springfield,
Missouri,
Missouri.
I spent from Missouri this Saturday.
Get on the new bureau form.
Um,
get the details at 10th planet J J.
Dot Com.
All right,
bitches.
We will see you guys on Wednesday.
I think I over bitches.
I did one more.
It's on an artificial that last bitches.
I take it back.